what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and as you
already know if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first is that we have two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily also guys you may not know
this but just pearly things is a
networked apt Network and under our
Network we have two talents Auntie Jenny
and King Richie's make sure you go
subscribe to both of their channels
um they have shows on the days that I
don't do shows so we do have have live
shows six days a week and then Mondays
and Saturdays we have it um twice a day
so we have eight shows a week that the
network puts out we're also going to be
doing a dating Series where um King
Richie's is trying to do a five dollar
date can you make a good date off of
five bucks find out go subscribe to his
channel
um a couple other announcements we have
four membership tiers the first tier
lets you be a part of the live chat
today the second interior you get to see
my Discord and my behind the scenes
Vlogs do you want to see me freestyle
rap go sign up for the second tier third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media this means having access to
my inbox in the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month do
you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for the
fourth tier also guys they took away my
Instagram so go follow just pearly
things one and they also took away my
first second third and fourth Tick Tock
so go follow just pearlythings.5 on Tick
Tock also guys we have wife school I
don't know when the bread kneading
episode is coming out but I did learn
how to knead Brad if you want to know
how to need Brad go subscribe to that
channel
um
also guys we have a new animation
Channel just pearly animations
um also King Richie's is doing a workout
Channel or doing some workout videos on
his channel so if you want to see some
workout content go there also we are
going to do a meet up in London um I
think somewhere in central London we
have the place picked out I think it's
going to be in the next two weeks if you
want to be notified for where it is um
sign up for our email list uh blessing
can you make sure that's in the
description or in the comments yeah okay
thank you or moderators I think Doug has
the link too
um also guys we only have one official
pregame page on Instagram
and a thousand likes and we will we will
open up the live chat okay it's a lot of
announcements so um welcome to the show
ladies
today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself starting
here and then go around well my name is
Sharon I'm 22 years old my relationship
status is
complicated and what is it's complicated
mean
um I'm not in a really okay I'm dating
you're dating yeah is that like I said I
I think is that a situationship I just I
like to be in the know I like to yeah
it's not really a situationship um we're
just getting to know each other okay
yeah taking things slow being helpful
how would you even describe what Dayton
is like even when someone says oh are we
dating and I'm not are we dating where's
the situation so I'm like what is what
is the state of mean we need to clarify
this right now I feel like okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna clarify what I have you
guys can tell me if I'm Runner I feel
like dating is going on a couple dates a
situation ships means you're hooking up
with them and
no no you're you're right yeah doing the
deed okay yeah right right okay if you
go on a date with situationships yeah a
word yeah
I do let me know I can't believe it
thank the Lord I've just gone out of
that situation
okay so a fun fact about me I am a Tarot
reader so I do tarot cards oh yeah I
didn't expect that did you yeah
[Music]
yeah go ahead
um I'm Dania I'm 22 and I am single
never been in a relationship
and I'm a pole dancer oh wow
wow okay hi guys my name is Titi
um I'm 22 years of age
and I think I'm single I can't really
like okay I don't know how to put myself
okay you want
I don't know okay how do we not know if
we're single or not do you have a
boyfriend no so you're single I'm single
I'm single guys
it's very good to be single you have
your own life
okay cool guys I'm single and I'm not
ready to mingle sorry about that
seriously you're single but not I love
that not looking I'm single and too busy
too busy I'm way too busy so if any guy
wants to slide it's going to be seen
even if it's like Michael B Jordan yeah
you're gonna sweep me off my feet type
of thing do you get see me also only
celebrities in blue check marks
[Laughter]
she's bougie it's good to be bougie yeah
stand this you gotta have yours
and humble that exists
and fun fact
um
I used to run so I used to do 180 200
meters in relay so I don't know if
that's a shocker or it looks like oh my
God
you don't run anymore no she was walking
outside I saw her
[Laughter]
I'm 19
um relationship status is single and lit
yeah and I'm a singer
I've been on my socials at Supreme
official and yeah it wasn't a fun fact
which is to do a fun fact about me is
that I've got mad energy
I'm a sync I'm an artist
which is not very it is fun it is fun
so thank you guys for coming today guys
we are talking about toxic access now
whoa this is a young panel so I'm
I'm hoping this topic still works
no question what what is your definition
of a toxic X
someone that feels Untitled to making
decisions for you
[Music]
someone that feels entitled to to your
life to your lifestyle but that also
determines on whether you give them that
intact whether you give them that but do
you don't like it when a guy has a bit
of like control that with me even though
I have a lot of control in my career and
in my life but I like to feel you know
petite and cute because I like when a
man is like give it to me I'd like to
have like a bit of um controlling that
oh where are you yeah I'm gonna say I
want to know you care about me because
we'll say like the whole controlling
thing shows you that he cares as well I
think that's important in any
relationship yeah and this is confused
you're nodding and she says this you
agree because but she's saying the
opposite of what you said
she's taking her
account text that she means like toxic
oh like in an angry way yeah in a
controlling way as in
I would want you to show me that you
care I get that I like that I think she
means I can't lie I can't like show me
that you want you won't chase me
show me that you want me I don't like
you you don't want to feel entitled to
making decisions yes but you want him to
chase you okay you want I'm just running
the steps yes
there's a huge difference between
controlling and a bit of dominance and I
think that as a woman I think in a
relationship like a man that has a
little bit of dominance I think
controlling and like constantly checking
where you are I feel like it's a bit too
much in my opinion anyway I feel like
there should be a level of trust in a
relationship
but no one I said when I said well like
where are you it's more of like oh are
you safe are you at home yet okay yeah
so that's different yeah okay what's the
difference between controlling and
dominance I think a dominant man is
someone that can like make decisions
like say for example like we're going on
a date okay I'm picking you up at eight
I'm taking you somewhere like that's
kind of like dominance or like did you
get home safe or you know checking up on
you and making sure you're good but like
instead of being like where are you what
are you doing who are you with show me
who you're with you you can't wear that
outfit like that is very tough so so you
want them to be able to make the
decisions but not the decision of what
to wear
[Laughter]
oh babe I want you to put that sexy
outfit you look good in that okay are
you cute that's cute that means he
trusts you though don't you think
there's a level of trust
is manipulation not I don't think you
guys are really aren't answering the
question by what she said what is a
toxic you guys are just saying the guys
being controllers and manipulative I
feel like those are two different things
yeah I agree with that okay what do you
think I feel like a toxic relationship
is when two people are going at each
other for but in a way where you know
that what one person's saying is not
good and what another person seems not
good but it's like
in your head it's it's good to them but
in the end it's not good so it's like
you guys are fighting and battling like
okay what's like what's what's it's like
yeah you're clashing with each other
yeah you might love each other to Pieces
but if it doesn't work and you have that
Clash all the time yeah then that's what
makes it toxic so extreme exciting yeah
okay knowing that it's not good but
you're still doing and you're still
together
yeah so knowing it's not good but
staying together yeah yeah what about
what about rough patches and marriages
um I think rough patches and marriages I
mean because don't you argue all the
time during a rough patch in a marriage
you wouldn't think I agree but if you're
married to someone it's a lifelong
commitment and I think those are things
that you should be able to work through
by communication there's even like yeah
it's couples therapy even like if you
need to do it if you're willing to like
work through that then you can get
through it but yeah everyone argues yeah
see it's just it's very broad everything
you guys are saying I'm just trying to
lock you down under one thing uh go
ahead I feel like it depends on what the
topic of conversation is and what you
guys are arguing about that then depends
if it's toxic or thing where I'm
correcting you and what you're doing is
wrong yeah wait say that again sorry
that all depends on what you guys are
arguing about for you for YouTube for
you to know whether it is toxic or thing
where you're just correcting a person
because
yeah
what wouldn't be an example of something
that's toxic and something that's not
I've got one of course that's a good one
pictures on Instagram following bad
girls that is toxic in itself I'm sorry
I think it do you think it's don't you
think it's toxic to be constantly
looking who she's following and he's
liking it
sometimes it takes two to tango yeah but
I ended the day yeah if you really like
one that person and you like the person
you're with like why did you need to
seek elsewhere well you need to have
temptations yeah but why are you gonna
get upset over an Instagram like true
because there's no actual double tap in
it because you clearly like what you're
thinking about aren't you aren't you if
you like what you're seeing it you don't
think you're looking for drama in a way
I'm trying to see if I can trust him
you're doing it for trust me
shouldn't you go into relationships in
good faith no no no everything she's
saying is by the reasons but yes as you
know we are gen Z the way things were
back then is totally different you guys
didn't have social media you guys didn't
have phones
I mean thank you guys I mean you've
never had before I had a phone
exactly like you'll go to them you you
traps them right but now trapsing is
double tapping because it says a lot
about a man's discipline as well that's
really okay what about what about when
girls post selfies while in a
relationship
is double tapping and liking a girl's
picture that's showing like yes you're
you're attracted to them and when they
say would you say a toxic girl post
selfies and and while she's in a
relationship if her intention sorry if
her intention is to get a reaction out
of that from a certain audience then yes
but what if his intention was just to
like the picture why would you just like
a and if anything let's have an open
conversation yeah you know what that's
yeah because I don't like a single guys
picture or you know what I mean because
I would why would I give them the
satisfaction of seeing Mia me in their
notifications no thank you I mean to be
honest I don't really think that liking
a girl's Instagram picture is that deep
I think obviously if they go ahead and
DM them and message them yeah well you
can appreciate someone's but you're free
you're praying you're putting the goal
but you can just go through
couldn't you say the same thing about
women that post-suggestive Instagram
pictures while in a relationship that
they're they're looking for attention
even if it's just a selfie you know that
men are not you know how men are you
know well if they're in an open
relationship
complete different topics yeah it just
it really it really it's about body and
female empowerment in the day so we've
got all things
it really just it really just sounds
like you want you want to do whatever
you want but he can't do whatever he
wants yeah
[Laughter]
with a man there should be a level of
trust there so you just you know that
already if he's like another Instagram
post it's never that deep because
the trust isn't but you shouldn't be in
a relationship with someone you don't
trust the trust should be there before
you get into something what do you think
about that happening during a dating
like when you're dating like the dating
base I mean should it shouldn't you go
into a relationship in good faith like
assuming the best but let's say you're
just dating you're not in a relationship
but you're about to get into the
relationship but then you you know what
I mean it's I kind of think you're
overthinking okay too much yeah I think
I mean if you guys are together and it's
something serious and then he starts to
go and follow loads
that's different I'm talking in the
dating phase well you're getting to know
each other and he's still lacking other
gods people you're both single so you
have the rights to do whatever you want
I think unless it becomes something
serious if you're single you're going to
chat to whoever and they're going to
chat to whoever and then if you decide
that it's something that is worth trying
for then you guys cut off your links or
you do whatever
because relationship with more based of
trust right yeah and then dating is more
for
I don't even know man I think um
[Music]
finish your men or what a man I just
who do you think is more promiscuous men
or women
I feel like they're both promiscuous in
different ways I feel like females I
feel like you know what these days some
of the some of these females they use an
Instagram like a dating app I don't know
what is going on they're posting that
all these random pictures that bro you
don't have to do all of that focus on
yourself and your career that are you
trying to get attention from I think a
lot of God there's attention seeking
girls on Instagram when it comes to
take one who's who's more promiscuous
promiscuous yeah if we're talking about
like visually
you know I'm talking about who's who
sleeps around more oh oh who's okay I'll
miss my question you say man yeah I say
men men again yeah I'm gonna give you
guys a stat do you know one in three men
under 30 are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year
do you think one in three women under 30
are either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
no
I'm gonna say women sleep more than men
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy though oh
my god do you guys
um do you guys like tall guys are you
tall guys you like short Kings I mean as
long as that's older than me I'm sure as
it is
five seven babe have you heard have you
heard girls say that they need a guy
over six foot yeah all the time do any
of you have an X that's over six years
as long as you're taller than me do you
have an X over six foot
yeah yeah
okay
so what percent of guys do you think are
over six foot
one percent
lucky guess 56 56 I'm gonna say 35 35 42
42. huh
um Harmony
I'm not drunk guys
um I would say 30 30 so it's only 15 of
guys wow and now think about it think
about it if uh how many people said they
have an X over six foot you did you did
you did all sleeping with the same guys
huh
that's what I mean
General are sleeping with the same guys
because 80 of women want 20 of men
no that is Matt so so the reason like
women think men are trash and they think
they're sleeping around all the time is
because we go for such a small
percentage of of men and they are
sleeping around all the time yeah the
majority of men if you go to Tesco you
think they're getting a new play
so you'll see it and you're saying it
comes to our choice in men right that
makes us think the rest of the same I
think that's the first statement
actually yeah I agree with that
yes that's a very interesting thing
because I feel like a lot of the time
like women when they're younger yeah
they go for like the bad boy or like
something and as you get older you kind
of realize that like certain traits that
you would like find attractive like
someone who's emotionally unavailable
they become unattractive as you get
older you're only 22 right I know what
have you been in a relationship but you
know I've seen so many like people get
into relationships and it's just and it
all flops something and it's like yeah
I'm scared
I'm actually terrified so um have you
guys had a toxic ax yep yes
um it wasn't an X but I guess yeah sort
of toxic yeah okay nope I've had people
who felt like they're obliged
by having a say in my life because they
like me
that's not yes or no I need a yes
no me I would say yeah yeah okay um how
long were you involved with your toxic
ex a year and a half yeah did you love
him yes yes five years five years oh my
oh my goodness that is mad five years
yeah that's crazy did you love him
that's how you know it's toxic five
years you didn't love him I don't know
it was I wasn't like in a relationship
with him but it was just a very toxic
situation so
okay so you know you didn't love him yes
or no
um I don't know maybe it was love to me
at the time at the time I don't think
his love like now when I look back on it
okay wow five years okay so I actually
never been in a relationship like
properly where I can say oh you know
with boyfriend and girlfriend yeah but
I've been in a lot of situations where
I'm dating a guy and I would say yeah I
miss going it's been quite toxic so yeah
you would yes yes and how long were you
with him oh
I was with him for about
must be not five months not long five
months yeah I'm a busy woman I haven't
really got time did you did you love him
no no
okay so question question based on this
panel two out of four of you said you
loved your toxic acts and you were with
him for over a year would you say by
that statement young women love toxic
men
yes yes do you know what it is I think
when you're young you don't really know
your boundaries properly yet and a lot
of people put up with stuff that they
wouldn't usually put up with like I
always say now like men only treat you
bad if you let them if you let them yeah
if you let them treat you bad and you
don't if you don't respect your
boundaries then they're gonna walk all
over you and I think that's just bad
guys though I think that's just bad guys
like I think there's something about
young women like picking the bad boys
[Music]
I'm gonna walk all over you if you treat
them well that's just yeah no 100 I'm
the youngest in here and I will tell you
yeah it's because it's exciting it's
like almost like an adrenaline
bounce off each other I knew it when she
was talking about the following I was
like she likes to draw
yeah literally but I also feel like yeah
it's not sorry I also feel like it
depends on your circumstances as the
young girl because I with me I depended
on my ex for living for food for
everything so I felt like I was chained
to him like I was his had no one else
you know so it was like circumstances
made me in be in that situation so what
about that situation was toxic uh well
he was basically like cheating around
flirting with other girls at work
um I didn't know obviously because I was
just like at home I didn't have a job I
was just like living off him you know
but I feel like he he
um had that power over me because I
allowed him to obviously so yeah so she
was it more than cheating or was he a
good boyfriend outside it was more than
cheating I was involved in certain
things as well so I felt like if he did
if he could do I could do it to you okay
so you were cheating you were both
cheating on each other yeah and couldn't
you just done a standstill and then got
along
um no because I mean
we did have conversations about it we we
were very open with each other but then
obviously the cheating was lies he
because he kept it from me so did you
keep your cheating from him no I told
him I told him you don't want you don't
know you don't want to know who I
cheated on him with but um
is he famous no he's not no no no okay
do I know no you don't
okay I cheated on him with his sister
listen if you break me I will break you
back
[Laughter]
me and his sister were really good
friends I mean clearly
we were really good friends and
obviously one day she said she wanted to
come over and I said cool he was at work
we got drunk and she started like
pouncing on me okay I'm not even trying
to like I'm so serious like she and I
was like no like this isn't right and
she's like no and then Boop that
happened and I was like [__] and then
you told him yeah I told him how did he
react he almost killed me was she
younger how old was she she was younger
yeah but we had a conversation about it
and
I can't pay out his ethnicity anyway
um it's it's almost like common from
where he's from
wearing that
okay so South Africa wow
no but um it's not coming but it was
like a thing within his
[Laughter]
regardless of whether I did something
wrong or not regardless of whether I
hurt someone's feeling or not I am an
honest person and I feel like that's
very very important if you're if you're
talking to someone if you're in a
relationships with someone if you're
just with people anyway you know so I I
just I clarified that with him he got
upset he came back and he was like thank
you for being honest with me you know so
it was like yeah but he was toxic for
cheating on you and not telling you yes
I had to find out would you would you
rather have him told you yes do you
think men lie to women they care about
or that they or they tell the truth to
women they lie to women they care about
and they feel like maybe like certain
characteristics that they have for
example
um some because some women are really
Stern like if you cheat on me that's it
and because they care so much they don't
want to lose you so that thought of
having to lose you would now be in be in
the head obviously and yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't tell you so
outside of the cheating anything else
toxic or just that
um
yeah we smoked a lot of stuff
okay so I guess that's drugs
I guess that was toxic again okay
um all right what about you
um
what was the question
um what was toxic about you said you had
a toxic situationship yeah what was
toxic about it um it was very
emotionally abusive so like even though
I see myself as a strong person but
there's only so many times you can like
get knocked down and I dealt with it and
I feel like I didn't respect my own
boundaries which led to me being in that
situation
um yeah it was just very unhealthy what
is emotional abuse
um I think to constantly knock someone's
confidence down make them feel bad about
themselves
like what specifically
um
I don't know like it could really be
anything like you know just I'm asking
to you like what did he say like what
how was he emotionally abusive oh he
just like just used to knock me down
like I used to be a bit slow because I
had a history of like doing like party
drugs okay I feel like it actually
affected my like mental development a
bit like I had a stutter for a long time
like I was a bit slow and it was one of
my biggest insecurities and I used to
get digged out a lot for that like oh
you're so slow you're stupid you're this
and that's what he would say to you yeah
and also
um I lost a lot of weight because of
stress and I was very insecure in my
skin like you're so skinny like lost so
much weight and it just makes me feel
like a bit rubbish about myself
um and what did what did you say to him
back like did you push back or what yeah
I would push back I would tell him like
don't talk to me like that or I don't
like that I'm running because he did
used to like threaten me and stuff but
he used to threaten you yeah he was he
wasn't like threatened threatened to do
like what kill you or no like just to
like you know bring his fists up to me
and stuff I knew he would never do
anything but like yeah it was just not a
nice situation I would always Stand My
Ground about that but I would continue
to put up with it for so long so that's
why
but I was disrespected for so long but
yeah literally after I got out of it I
put on weight like I was I got a glow
like life is good oh we love a happy
ending yeah
um what about no you you said yes
Maybe
[Music]
yeah
I relate to her as well because you know
what it is now I'm hearing both stories
maybe I haven't actually been in a toxic
um relationship we say or toxic X but
everyone has their own meaning of toxic
at the end of the day obviously I'm sure
there is like a meaning by book but
everyone has their like imagine yeah
yeah
meaning
yeah you know what I'm trying to say but
yeah basically I think with me obviously
um it wasn't for that long I think I
think most toxicity is like he was
saying he wanted to see me but didn't
see me and this was like that for about
eight months so he would say he'd want
to see you and then he wouldn't see you
because he constantly
your next plans with you and lets you
down and it's like
me you cannot take a bunch of me I'll be
like leave then stop believing me on I
said I'm not leaving you on have you
ever promised to go on a date and not go
when not went off again yeah are you
guys all toxic yeah
[Laughter]
guys you say like a rotation
entertainment hahaha but when a guy says
that he's toxic yeah yeah that's
absolutely because he says the exact
same thing that women can be just as bad
as men though some women are actually
demons like yeah evil pure evil yeah who
are you thinking of what story
no I've just like seen how like some
women treat men and like you know
um some women can be very narcissistic I
think
social media especially has like become
a breeding ground for narcissism in a
lot of people but I do also think the
times thrown around very Loosely and a
lot of people are accused of being a
narcissist when they're actually not
what girl you said you could think of a
narcissistic girls or a story give us
the two yeah yeah
[Music]
um I mean I could use like my
I don't know I don't know any
narcissistic women stories I've Heard
lots of stories and it's it's actually
like heartbreaking because a lot of the
time these men really care for these
women unless they're trapped in this
abusive you know what a lot of girls
trap guys by getting pregnant
a lot and then they have all this baby
mum and dad jump outside it's mad no but
you know what it is yeah when it comes
to like trapping a man with a baby you
need to be careful who you sleep with if
you're sleeping with people Loosely and
you you run the risk of getting that
person pregnant so you have to you have
to sit like that
remember we said earlier about if you
you're only going into placement date
that person you do that person if you
want to be with them and you're getting
very short because of trust and then
you'd only sleep with that person if
you're like don't mean that yeah at the
same time at the same time if you don't
want to be anything you need to wrap up
because yeah yeah as much as it takes
two to tango you need to protect
yourself for your own good like yeah
yeah the woman can say she's on the pill
she's on this she's on that but like but
still at the same time protect yourself
you said you've you've heard of a girl
trapping a guy tell me about that oh no
obviously
[Music]
um yeah he was obviously dating I think
this like girl only fans go and
um yeah and then obviously his energy
kind of Switched right and she was quite
um
because she used to I have some other
girls she used to block she used to go
on his phone and block certain goals oh
wow and um he used to go and she'd go
through people's like insta stories and
staff friends who who he follows that
makes sense yeah that makes sense yeah
and then afterwards
um
obviously who knows how she got pregnant
oh well yeah and then um but obviously
again it was it was it wasn't serious he
was doing it mainly for pleasure because
of her body right she's got a nice body
okay cool what else can you bring to the
table you know we've got beautiful lady
panelists tonight we've all got body
body yeah but we need yeah I mean but
we've got more than that hence why we're
here today that's right that's what I'm
trying to say but obviously in the in
that case I'm obviously trapping him
it's crazy because now it's messed up
his career a little bit he obviously
didn't want it he did not really taking
responsibility and he's kind of like
hiding away from everyone almost and
obviously that can impact the man
mentally as well and I think a lot of
people don't focus on a man's mental
health as well and I think females are
all like are we emotional um we've got
feelings but obviously men are taught to
obviously keep that away but but also
what I would say is like once a woman
like when a woman actually falls
pregnant it's a very very very difficult
decision to make whether to keep it or
to get rid of it
um
how do you fall pregnant
yeah it's an actual baby so I mean you
might tell yourself oh I don't want a
baby and then you fall pregnant and
you're like oh [__] like what have I
done yet what have I done like I
actually want to keep this baby now or
I'm gonna that's what I feel like a lot
of people do you guys don't think about
the consequences of your actions you're
always relying I feel like this
generation is so much awareness yeah
like are you present are you aware of
like what you're doing and the concept
Our Generation yeah mostly women yeah so
we go back to what you say to women I
would say women use it as a foreign
[Music]
people might have different
um views but I say that's not good yeah
I think if you don't want to get
pregnant then you need to like take the
precautions to not get pregnant
obviously if you need to have an
abortion then like you get it
yeah I know because there's women out
there that can't have children and then
if you get a lot of abortions that can
actually stop you from having kids in
the future that is very true that is
very true because I took the pill so
many times I now suffer from polycystic
ovarian syndrome so it's hard for me to
actually get pregnant
unfortunately I haven't seen my period
for four years but recently I got my
period through some profit that prayed
for me and yeah I'm delivered guys
miracle from like from what did you get
it from the pill like like do you mean
the morning after pill or the the
morning after pill yeah I took that too
many times and I also went on the pill
how many times did you take it I think
like six seven times six seven times
within the span of how long
um within oh maybe like a month six
seven in a month wow yeah and did you
know that was a possible side effect no
I didn't and how did you find out that
you had that this was actually well what
the polycystic over yeah when I was in a
relationship with my toxic ex because I
noticed that he would obviously inside
of you and then I would notice that I
wasn't like getting pregnant and I was
gaining so much weight really quickly
and
um I started growing excess excess hair
in certain places so those are all the
side effects of getting um polycystic
ovarian syndromes and then I went to the
doctors found out I had it and yeah
what was that like for you it was scary
because I love kids I'm I am a child
myself you know like I love laughs I
love playing I love to just be me
everywhere so kids was a big factor for
me but I knew that in due time things
will work out in my favor and I will get
the kids that I want it's not impossible
not to have kids but it's harder 10
times harder do you wish they told you
about that um before you before I took
yes a thousand percent yeah that's um a
thousand percent because I feel like a
lot of girls really don't know about the
side effects and they don't discuss them
the doctors don't tell you I've never
really been on it because when I heard
about birth control I was like you're
gonna stop me from getting pregnant yeah
education I followed education in that
aspect when it comes to contraception
methods it's not that good the teacher a
little bit at school but not completely
but even when you go and like get it
prescribed the doctor don't really tell
you nothing and you know what there's so
many women that go on contraception and
then they can't they struggle to get
pregnant afterwards then they're like oh
fertility goes back to normal straight
away and it doesn't and some people are
trying for a baby and three years down
the line they still can't have a child
because they've been everyone's body is
different as well everyone's Body Works
differently yeah yeah yeah it's hard
do you guys believe that the label toxic
is overused in relationships today yes
look at me like what time
you've been liking about that come on
now like really I don't know hearing
their stories that you know there's
different like I said it's different um
Heights of toxic levels of toxicness and
again it's what you perceive the word
toxic to mean so but I do think that
toxic relationships and like just with
anyone like friends yeah partners and
stuff it's like really like promoted on
social media it is it is like the toxic
relationship Lifestyles like toxic love
like everyone yeah and what's his name
blue face
so much I don't get so much attention
for that and it's like so unhealthy
they're probably so both so depressed
and unhappy I feel like trying to be
toxic you have to have a very strong
head yeah like they have to be toxic
they know what they're doing it's like
they don't it's not like they don't know
what they're doing it's like it's like
it's calculated yeah they're doing it on
purpose but what I've seen that's what
it looks like yeah I mean to be honest I
feel like with toxic relationships you
get that Adrenaline Rush from like when
things are good and then when it goes
like really bad you just think about the
good times which is why are you stay
with that person you feel like you're
making excuses for yourself to stay yeah
and obviously it's so up and down like
once it goes down you're like oh my God
I can't wait for it to like go back up
again like and everything to be good
because you guys go through like really
good faces a little bit of Hope almost
yeah good part or sometimes you just use
yeah
the cons will eventually outweigh the
pose I mean that's when you know how do
you get used to it
no because some people have grown up in
even like a toxic household like with
toxic families like also like how
someone's been raised has a big impact
on like the type of men they go for
women also like drama
[Music]
why not women watch sports that's
camaraderie we like the Kardashians oh
my gosh the Kardashians
[Laughter]
I don't know
watch sitting with Kim Kardashian she's
gonna be me and her gonna be pretending
that manifestation
we're working on you know skins X I've
got a private land dropping suit as well
driving my music so mad Madness told you
I'm such an EastEnders fan so I can't
you know what I like it
every single day but then the the
storyline is just too dark for me like
it's so negative at to a point you might
be able to handle it but like it got to
a point where I could not I could not
anymore but that is toxic actually
question what is toxicness and where
does it come from
I think something that's not good for
you but you want it you go for it anyway
but something that's genuinely like bad
for your your mental health and I think
and you do it anyway a long duration
where does it stem from though
where does it stand from I think well
toxic relationships stem from lack of
boundaries I'm talking about toxic not
toxic relationship there's two different
toxic itself what is it toxic there's
something harmful something dangerous
people use that for food
[Music]
have you guys ever been labeled a toxic
X like would your exes say that you're
toxic yes yes yeah
no I haven't no
no but I would say I could be toxic if I
choose to be toxic yeah
exactly that that's the energy yeah yeah
I agree with the energy I agree with
that that's why I said for you to be
toxic you have to have a strong head and
people know what they do when they be
toxic it's not like no it's like a mind
game 100 I agree what do you think have
you ever been labeled to toxic ax with
Drax to say you're toxic they would they
would say I'm toxic maybe because I'm
not admit as me
from toxic because um because
um
because I was in the past that was 10
minutes ago
but yeah I don't think I would be called
toxic
how do you guys think past relationships
shape future relationships
you know the difference between lust and
love oh my goodness you know the
difference between that is I feel like
if you're able to reflect if you're able
to reflect and not carry on the patterns
that you had in your past relationship
100 you need to be self-aware yeah 100
like Erica Perdue said yes in that song
bag lady she's like Pack Light because
if you bring all your emotional baggage
yeah into your future relationships
they're never gonna work no one wants to
deal with your bag is she married now or
no Erica I think she's got a kid I don't
know she's got a kiss
really yeah wow I didn't I didn't know
who she was though no way yeah she was
cool though I love her she's she's sick
do you guys think that the best
predictor of uh future relationships is
past relationships yeah yeah yeah I
don't think so because I feel like in
life like if you go into a relationship
and you learn the lesson that it's
taught you after you've broken up
then no but if you don't learn the
lesson then the universe is just going
to keep sending you the same person in a
different body and you're going to have
to keep
[Laughter]
it hold on hold on hold on I'm adding
that to my lesson wait wait wait wait
I'm adding that to my list of things
like I want girls to stop saying the
universe but you know what some people
really genuinely believe them no yeah
the universe does because if not if not
why is it that the same person with the
same character traits with the same
habits with the same comments again
I can I can break it down for you
choices yeah
I'm saying like you either like toxic
you probably like toxic people and
you're probably toxic at the same time
girls will take accountability off of
them and say it's the it's and I'm not
trying to pick on you but it's like
they'll say the universe and then it's
like it might not be the universe it's
probably you but at the same time though
a lot of toxic relationships don't start
off toxic they start off like normal
relationships
honey they change after the honeymoon
phase that's true what I would say is
yeah poor choices but it's because you
haven't learned your lesson the first
time yeah exactly and there's only so
many relationships you're going to go
through before you need to look inwards
and be like okay maybe I'm the problem
yeah and I but self-reflection is hard
you know yeah
it might not start toxic but then you
probably do something that's toxic
relationship yeah no one's perfect so
actually relating to what you said it
makes sense because when you said
environment and um
how it relates I feel like it makes
sense and when you said issue
environment and you so it all depends on
where you come from your upgrade
upbringing and what makes you who you
are so I feel like when you're in
relationship a past relationship can
make your future relationship better but
how that makes it better is by you know
yourself
[Music]
reflection if you don't reflecting
yourself or if you don't know yourself
or if you don't do battle if you
continue to do the same thing it's like
wherever you see on whether you're not
even expectation that is what you're
going to attract do any of you guys go
to the gym are you guys yeah I guess
sometimes I go so if you if you're
practicing squats you get better at
squatting right so wouldn't you say the
only way to get better at being a
healthy relationship is to be in a
healthy relationship how would you I
would think so but also I think to be in
a healthy relationship you need to know
what your boundaries are and you need to
like respect them like going back to
boundaries again like if you have set
boundaries and you respect your own
boundaries and you have a level of
self-respect for yourself then it sets
the tone for other people to come into
your life and respect those boundaries
what kind of boundaries are helpful in a
relationship I think a level of trust
being able to give people space if they
need it okay to trust you know not being
like controlling or anything and being
controlling okay yeah I mean everyone's
boundaries are kind of different it kind
of depends on the person but and I think
it also depends on that you've got to be
independent as a woman and be okay with
being on your own I need to learn to
love yourself it's codependency that
really issues it believes it's like okay
it's cool he can leave you know what I
mean I've got a lot of girls rely a lot
of guys a lot of girls depends do you
know anyone that's been married for 30
plus years
yeah 20 plus years not 20 20 plus years
do you feel like that's the woman's
mentality is I need a lot of boundaries
and I need to not need him
I think it's about not needing the
person but I think that's what there's a
fine line between like there could be
something having your own life and then
like codependence I mean like some some
like girls they make their relationship
their whole life and then they break up
with their partner and they're lost they
don't have no friends anymore because
they drop out all their friends like
they don't know themselves they lose
their whole personality because they've
made their whole life their
relationships
I'm a couple years older than you and
usually those girls actually end up
getting into a relationship and starting
a family Young
so it's just like instead of like you
guys might have different skills like
you're good at singing you're good at
that those girls just have relationship
skills so they just usually they just
usually get into another relationship
but then they they find another guy
because she proved she could be a good
girlfriend to that one so that she goes
into another yeah some people are just
relationship people I think they're just
made to like be in a relationship some
people have the goals of like well
they're just not young or they're just
not even just they they just get taken
advantage off yeah that's a very very
like fine there's a very very fine line
between that I think because yeah
there's a lot of fun just make a man
their whole life because it gives them
validation because they don't love
themselves yeah and when you don't love
yourself like I know it's cliche but
like how can you expect someone to love
you properly if you don't love and
respect yourself how would you expect
them to love you yeah you need to set
the tone for them you know if you show
them that you don't respect yourself and
you don't love yourself then how are
they gonna do how are they going to love
you and respect you so how do you show
them that I just I always hear these
terms with girls and I just it's always
so broad don't give them too many
chances you know what I mean you know
like yeah yeah don't give them too many
chances okay do you think the 30-year
marriage 20-year marriage the the
longest marriage you know you think the
woman's mentality was don't give him too
many chances no no I'm just I'm talking
about successful outcomes so if we look
at people with with good outcomes
because we'd all agree long marriage is
better than nobody breaking up right
yeah okay but I'm talking I'm talking
about like the dating like when you're
dating before you get into it because
like I said I haven't actually been in a
proper relationship so I can only go of
experience from dating so I'm gonna say
I know these guys think some of you have
been a relationships
but like I I haven't so yeah but I feel
like you have to make sure what was the
question again do you do you think that
do you think that the mentality of cut a
guy off quick it was good for a
long-term relationship don't give him
too many no if he's cheating then yeah
you've got it because he will most
likely do it why do we always go to like
the worst case scenario I think I think
um because of female in the beginning I
think if someone like if you express
that you don't like how someone's
treating you and then they continue to
treat you like that and then you still
take them back that's unhealthy that's
not you not respecting your boundaries
because you don't like the way you're
being treated but you're going to stay
there because you like him or you think
that he likes you because he does nasty
things to you and then he might buy some
flowers afterwards and be like oh I'm so
sorry but then he does it again like
oh that's unhealthy do you know what I
mean like a space of experience that's
not good but like if you're in a
long-term marriage or you're in a
relationship and you have a few issues
that you don't you don't like agree on
certain things those things can easily
be resolved with good communication
yeah I mean I agree with you that you
should cut people off that aren't
married if you want to be married that
aren't marriage minded and quick but I
think sometimes like as women we always
jump to like the worst case scenario
it's either cheating I only know this
I've done these shows so many times yeah
we have fantasies
to get better before I used to always
think of the worst case scenario but now
I'm like
um
sometimes you just gotta go with the
flow like yeah literally you do you
can't think too much into it obviously
if you're not being treated right then
obviously he's got to go yeah 100 it's
as simple as that okay
um
can a person change and no longer be
considered a toxic X yes 100 I think
they can change when they look inwards
what do you think
um no
you don't think people can change no
depending on how long you're trying to
get them to change
depending on how long do you have no but
you know what it is a man or a woman
anyone will only change when they're
ready to change yeah force them to
change because they're never they're
never going to change for you like if
you stay with a man hoping that he will
change he's not gonna change for
you've got to be genuine as well it's
got to be a genuine change yeah like
it's got a last yeah and don't forget
like sometimes you know guys I'm sure go
through stuff as well like certain
triggers might trigger them to like step
back toxic not toxic attributes to like
you know come back that aren't healthy
so that needs to be taken into a cat as
well when he makes that change that has
he completely like looked within himself
that we keep saying and like what about
herself well it's just interesting
whenever I say toxic sex we always say
man what about her I think it's because
we're all kind of like oh yeah
yeah but like a toxic girl you know
because you said you knew a lot of toxic
girls or you've seen that situation
toxic relationships and I've seen like
toxic relationships with a woman is like
the aggressor or like the the toxic
person and did she change
um I don't know her well enough to know
that so I can't really speak on it but
um
yeah people some people change but you
know what it is again like
self-reflection is really hard to do
when you have to look inwards and look
at yourself on your own flaws a lot of
people would rather ignore that because
ignorance is bliss as someone in the
chat said people only change when the
reality of their life convinces them to
make a change yeah
big situations happen or something that
would just yeah so yeah yeah I mean to
break every chain I feel like a lot of
people have to hit rock bottom for them
to realize okay I need to change this I
need to like that's true yeah
that's true one time I was dating a guy
that my dad didn't like and
um I said I said dad do people change
that was a couple of years ago and he
looks at me and he says yes
they get worse over time
it's gonna be worse than 10 years so we
should choose carefully because it's not
going to get better
no it's true though because it will just
get under your skin more word as the
time goes on if you don't like something
you're not vocal about it from the
beginning
acts a person a person can only fix
themselves and for them to fix
themselves they have to make countless
mistakes in order for them to realize yo
whoa what am I doing that's it 100 I
agree with that and that includes sorry
sorry that includes going back to the
triggers you were talking about because
without those triggers how would you
know that you're ready for change or
you're ready to change you know okay I
think a lot of people can like
um based our like toxicity of like about
upbringing and stuff but you know what
you get to a certain age where you need
to be held accountable for like your
behaviors and stuff not necessarily you
can't blame it you can't blame it on
your your childhood and stuff because at
the end of the day like you can see
someone who's got like grown up with
like alcoholic parents and actually
something I saw a post and it was like
twins and they grew up in a household
with like two alcoholic parents and one
of them became a complete alcoholic just
like his parents and the other one fixed
his whole life had a successful business
and stuff you know like if you you've
been given cards but it's just like it
depends what you want to do like you can
either learn from that and be like okay
I don't want to be like that I'm going
to make a change so I'm not that kind of
person or you can just be like Oh I'm
like that because my parents were like
that I'm like this because I grew up in
a bad environment
you think that's because of mindset it's
mindset so why did you say no the reason
why I said not necessarily was because
like she just said the first twin
decided to be more of an alcoholic and
the second Twin deciding make a change
of his life and there are two different
people but still one person still in the
same household but as you just said
mindset it depends on who you're around
with yes it is a decision but at the
same time
you can't do by yourself you need people
to help you 100 don't don't you get to
choose the people in your life yeah you
do by the same time over the age of
eight you guys have all come across me
but I'm pretty sure you guys are walking
across really bad people but you didn't
end up being like them you chilled with
them yeah but you're not them right but
at the same time you like realize like
okay I don't want to be like this so
you're not going to associate yourself
with people that again it's like we
start having having
um boundaries is that what you accept
into your life yeah 100 you know what I
mean the same way we don't have the same
bodies the same way we don't have the
same mindset no 100 a mindset is
something that you learn like over time
yeah and everyone's way of learning is
different at the same way school isn't
for everyone it's the same way the way
you take education differently yeah yeah
so I can't get there like change their
lives but at the same time like you
can't sit there and blame everything
else for the way your life's turned out
because everyone has a sub story like
everyone goes through [__] yeah but it
just it's like it's about how you it's
about how you deal with it you know if
you don't want to be in that situation
then you work towards getting yourself
out of that situation you know if you
sit there and you sulk and you're like
oh I'm in this situation and you don't
make no change like how do you expect to
grow how do you expect yeah exactly you
have to become the change and take
actions towards that change like
thinking and all of that is nothing with
that action you gotta continue
consistently execute it that's really
important
it is I have a question for you guys do
you think that people who constantly
label their exes as toxic are looking
for an excuse for the failed
relationship yes yes 100
yes yes I would say yes as well yeah
because it gets to a point again like
you need to look inwards if all of your
relationships are toxic and the other
person was always the bad person
look again
I'm just thinking now actually that
going back into whether I'm toxic I just
realized that I've never been a toxic
one
you've never you've never I've never
I've been I've always
[Laughter]
were you going through your ex's likes
were you
looking at who he followed
yes
no that's not toxic that's not toxic
that's seeing if I can trust him enough
guys
that's toxic
that's just one person out of how many
people in the world
[Laughter]
you said never you said no you never
talked about it but you know what it is
[Music]
my age not even my age I mean a lot of
girls that they say the same thing
obviously we spoke about the whole of
our dude covered already about
relationship that's different you're in
there for trust yeah but when you're
like dating and you're getting to know a
person I think you should be curious to
see whether you can trust them or not
it's out of curiosity you don't do it
all the time how can you trust someone
by looking at their Instagram followers
no no but what'd you mean because you
said oh you checked the followers to see
if you can trust them but how is
checking the followers scene you can try
no but you're just curious to see what
type of goals he follows deceptionalism
there or not question is how long do you
have to be curious for
I mean
are you able to see what type of corner
guy watches
[Laughter]
to me it's just like I don't know it's
Instagram guys look that's what they do
yeah like it's general in general like
if it's a pretty girl like you're gonna
appreciate the beat you're gonna like
the photo like the same way it's like if
you see pretty girl on the street you're
gonna look I don't know about you but
like whenever I go over because
[Music]
do you know a lot of prostitutes dudes
from what I've seen on someone on social
media okay yes it's a norm I was like in
your school did you know any no no I
think it's definitely an account I think
it's definitely blown up in popularity
not that it's blown up in popularity but
it's become more normalized even though
it was like it's the oldest like way of
making money for a woman like in the
world yeah but like yeah I think it
makes money social media it's definitely
like blown up in popularity and it's
more like in your face like yeah and the
reason why it's normal is because no one
has any Marvels no more does not exist
no more with me it does I'm talking for
myself that it does I know about you
guys but moves does not exist
listen I want some advice here what
would you guys do not advice not for me
but for watching what would you guys do
if if um he was in the DMS off the goals
he was lacking and following
um well I think that's about it together
I think that's a bit different I mean to
be honest if you're not together you're
not together here's the absolute freedom
to do it yeah until you decide that you
guys are both exclusive or you're
interested I know a lot of guys that
will read you know when you react with
the love heart eyes
what do we think about is that not DMs I
don't think that's really appropriate
yeah I don't think there's one reaction
I don't think it's appropriate but like
if you just like a photo like obviously
when you send that like the heart eyes
to the DM it's like basically starting
it's a really revealing photo
sheesh that's even worse no yeah that is
well see you guys are contradicting
exactly what we've you I was saying
before but to me right my question but
my question is how do you know that and
that's what I'm saying like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so
I'm saying how do you know that so if
you know that information you're
probably going through his legs going
through his following and you're going
so much
wait wait wait wait so my whole point is
that if you know all that information
you're probably toxic because you're
probably all over his [__]
I'm not I'm not saying that it's it's
okay for him to do that yeah but my
whole point is like a lot of times wait
wait my whole point is a lot of times
girls will will talk about how toxic he
is but it's like how did you find out
that information you're toxic too
because you've probably had some trauma
in the past or something that happened
in the past that makes you want to do it
in the future so even if it's a good guy
and you go into a relationship you're
not going in in good faith and you're
going to through all his [__] before
he's even done anything before you're
even dating no oh yeah it depends on the
length that girl is going to doesn't
make sense there's different levels of
it if it's like a one-time thing cool
maybe it's constantly then you've got a
lot of it it's still my question how do
you know
what do you mean because you're cute do
I mean you you'll see it I said I'm
scrolling Instagram I'll see you see the
likes there anyway
intentionally with the DMS you'd
obviously have to log into their
Instagram or go oh no I've never been in
that position that's not personal um
you're being intentionally curious to
know who he's like and who he's talking
to that's already toxic in itself
because how does it because how does it
make you feel when you do that how is
that but how does it mean it makes you
feel like [__] you're looking for
problems if you're going through his
likes I'm agreement and the crazy thing
is what y'all do
y'all go through the likes you'll go
through the following and instead of
just ending it no you start a fight and
you don't break up with him so it's like
why did you even go through it to begin
with Victor thank you
as well I've just not looked at it and
just lived your life because if you're
looking for something and you find it
what's gonna happen now okay and that's
what I say like I've just found that the
girls that do that stuff they just want
the drama and the fight and to fight and
then get back together and not break up
and it's like you know if she really saw
it and really ended it that would be one
thing but they never do
um
wanting the drama and wanting the fight
I don't think it's intentionally I want
to fight I want to find this drama it's
more of can I trust you can I trust you
that's trauma I think yeah I think it's
a bit of insecurity there because at the
end of the day like why would you get
into a relationship with someone you
don't trust yeah it doesn't make any
sense to me does he even like you with
like yeah if you're constantly if you're
in a relationship and you're constantly
trying to find out if he's doing
something you clearly don't trust him so
you shouldn't be with him you know
someone could break your trust after a
while yeah
yeah someone can break your trust over a
long time but if you don't trust someone
like and you're not willing to trust me
but you know you can trust someone then
and not not trusting them and that's
them breaking a trust that you thought
that you of course but I think a
relationship is the foundation of a
relationship
got a healthy relationship if you don't
trust me yeah yeah yeah I just think
it's healthier like okay if it comes to
you fine yeah yeah but it's like if
you're out looking for problems like
you're toxic yeah you can't at the end
of the day ignore it says Bliss yes like
if something's going on behind closed
doors and you're not aware of it and
he's keeping it on the download and like
you don't know nothing like it can't
hurt you yeah and you think that's okay
no I don't think it's okay
you know they're like what you don't
know can't hurt you and I agree with
that state you know but the thing is
it's like if you find something
suspicious and you don't trust them and
something does come to you then fair
enough but if you go out looking for it
it's like you're deliberately looking
for something to hurt you yeah yeah you
could literally call it a form of
self-harm
some trauma yeah no I think it's nice oh
my gosh trauma is going to war not your
ex-boyfriend
oh my God how does that I understand
what you're trying to say I'm not
disagreeing I'm not agreeing but is that
how does that cause problems within
yourself when that is a video a problem
which you now just found what are you
well because at the end of the day if
you're if you go out looking for the
problem you're talking about the likes
on Instagram the likes on Instagram I
mean to be honest like if you're not in
a relationship yeah even if you're in a
relationship I don't think it's a
problem if you like a girl's picture I
find it a problem when you start dming
them and trying to contact them and meet
up with them that is the issue but at
the end of the day like if you if you
don't someone then you should genuinely
shouldn't be with them the whole
question is how did you find it
it's one thing it's like okay it's one
thing if a girl DMS you and and says oh
he screenshots whatever and it comes to
you but if you're going through his
likes all the time going through his
Instagram going through his DMS going
through his following questions
even if you're just doing one of the
three it's like you're looking for
problems but how is that looking for a
problem man the problem was already
there okay how but why would that's not
that why would why because you're not
you're not you're not going into a
relationship in good faith you know what
good faith is yeah okay so so because
the question is why did you look to
begin with
there might have been something that
could trigger that okay but that there
might have been like for example you see
him like whenever you walk into the room
he quickly has his phone or that could
trigger your curiosity yeah right you
would want to know okay why is he hiding
his phone why is he doing that why is he
doing XY and said so that could be a
valid reason but then but why would you
get this why would you get that by that
reason I guess why would you get
triggered by the fact he has his phone
is it not from possible he doesn't feel
comfortable no no that's just him
physically showing you that he doesn't
feel comfortable you seeing what he's
doing on his phone why should you have
to hide the phone from me if you trust
me
well how about if you put this turns his
phone flat I think again though but I
think again sorry go ahead I think again
it links back to like insecurity and
trust issues and like maybe maybe issues
from past relationships yeah you see why
at the end of the day like because if
he's hiding us but I wouldn't think I've
never put in this in my life oh he's
hiding us but I just think oh he's just
putting it away
it's the way it's not about him oh yeah
oh babe you're here I want to give you
attention but the the whole thing is
like it's like leave him or just leave
it like yeah then leave him you don't
have to go through I guess some girls
want some um reassurance and there's
nothing wrong with that no there's
nothing wrong with reinsure something
that you may call problem doesn't mean
it is a problem
so at what cost like how often are you
going to go through his [__] like it's
like are you gonna go through it and
then now you're happy you're never gonna
go through it yeah you're not happy
after going through it you'll con you'll
dig yourself a hole and you'll before
you know it you're probably checking
every day but so is this guy doing where
is he he's
going on
problem in your head some of the time
like you might even create an issue in
your head which doesn't even exists
overthinking am I as crazy as that
sounds as crazy sounds some people
actually have to dig themselves a
problem
yeah no some people actually have to do
that yeah
they're in something toxic is that what
you mean yeah and some females just want
for the sake of argument just for
entertainment purposes to excitement
yeah I've never done that but obviously
yeah
the booth like yeah and that's the
difference between most females because
not all females are the same no 100 yeah
but again like if you if you feel like
you have to check their socials every
day and like I'm just checking what
they're doing and seeing what they're
doing okay
wait wait wait wait okay there's nothing
wrong with what there's nothing wrong
with checking with checking their
socials what do you mean by Checkers I
love her she's sticking up for me okay
okay
checking what by the way going back to
what she said like the likes and who
they're commenting I'm not talking about
the DM so I can't actually log into
these um Instagram and see DMS but
the the comment is basically going up
taking almost saying look good unless
that's their friend that's the whole
difference at all unless that's someone
that they knew before okay question do
you want to be married someday
yeah do you think that's healthy for a
long-term marriage do you think that's
the future of 16. he shouldn't be doing
it to successful marriages is to be
looking through your husband's following
who he's liking on Instagram all that
there's always something you can look
through yeah you know and sometimes you
take it out I mean some people meet the
husband's other family at the funeral
you know it just happened
is he just taken out but there's always
going to be something to look through
yeah 100 and so it's not necessarily
that he should be liking the photos it's
like the mindset behind it yeah
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second okay guys me hold on
sorry okay guys make sure you like the
video um that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these live streams so make sure you get
to a thousand likes today we will open
up the chat come on y'all a like is free
we are also reading all Super Chat so
make sure you send Super Chat and we
will read it
um
okay all right kcf's Sac they're
insecure because at the end of the day
they have nothing to offer men other
than depreciating looks and used box and
therefore they're replaceable black
Moses the chick on the end is justifying
her toxicity and is looking for issues
to be toxic KCF they are excuse makers
only go for guys that look like King
Richard Richie's
um Chief Kee Chief Keef um Pearl is this
Emoji red pill plus red head silly
sausage girls have 27 boundaries yet
when a guy has one boundary and you
break it and call him controlling the
politest way possible you are just
waffling Michelle Pearl add boundaries
to the list uh or at least the
definition of boundaries because that's
because what my man and family are my
whole life I'm alfro reap what you sow
you grow what you plant
um con Cortez I'm
I'm Sicilian I had a girl from Malta I
was a freshman she was a junior and she
loved seeing me for seeing me fight for
her definitely toxic um Alf afro regime
morning after pill is working for 72
hours after taking it why did you need
to take six to seven times a month
that's 18 to 21 days of coverage you
didn't know how when you ovulated um
Carlos X imagine a dude Ghibli saying
they had sex with a girlfriend's sister
on a show that will get at least
hundreds of thousands of views you can't
make this up
um Zoros um it's funny when modern women
think men and women are the same when
women sleep around their 304s and lose
value but men are the 304 makers
um modern okay okay that's all of it Let
me refresh the page really quick also
guys
um sign up for our form uh we are going
to be doing events in each cities we're
also going to do a red pill boxing event
so if you want to know who I think I
don't want to speak to soon but I'm 80
sure I have two YouTubers that are
willing to box so when I go back to
Chicago We're going to host like a whole
boxing event if you want to know who it
is sign up for our email list that is in
the description is it in the comments or
the description blessing
it's it's a pinned comment okay it's
pinned in the chat
um also we're gonna do meetups when I'm
in the US next month so we're gonna do I
think La
um Atlanta possibly Nashville
and Chicago they're just going to be low
like we're just going to send out texts
and whoever wants to come come it's
going to be at like a coffee shop or
something uh with security no weird
stuff okay yeah okay
um but make sure you guys like the video
I'm gonna refresh this real quick to see
if there's any more Super chats and then
we're gonna get back to the show
um okay
okay
do you think it's possible to have a
healthy relationship with a former toxic
accent in the future yeah oh yes
you've grown up you've leveled up you've
the mindsets are different and you've
both grown individuals as people and
you've done your self-reflection and
figured out how to love yourself and not
depending there's a lot of lag there's a
possibility so yeah it's not common but
like I think it's a possibility yeah if
you guys go your separate ways go like
you said I couldn't come back and then
yeah sometimes I've been to work I
couldn't work and it couldn't work yeah
[Music]
yeah how important is it to be honest
with yourself about past relationships
extremely because the last person you
would want to lie to is yourself that's
the last person have you ever lied to
yourself before
yes you have it's based on what she said
no no but I've always tried to be as
honest as possible and state out the
facts about certain situations I
possibly have lied to myself yes not
aware of right now but
um how did you grow from that oh
um
journaling
asking for advice asking for people's
opinions on my situation
and studying human behavior
okay like studying psychology no I just
literally naturally love to know people
for who they are and how they act and
their behaviors yeah it's a spiritual
thing yeah I do yeah it's a spiritual
thing with you
um yeah I definitely feel like I've lied
to myself because I feel like when
you're in a toxic situation and then you
make excuses for that other person you
make those excuses for yourself to
accept that their behaviors so I
definitely think yeah I have in the past
yeah I'll say definitely I have and the
reason why is to make it seem as if yeah
everything's old yeah
[Music]
it's like it's like I'm covering
something that I shouldn't have and the
reason why is because I don't really
know myself properly as of yet hence why
if I am treating myself I have no reason
to lie to myself to understand so yeah
what's the question have I asked myself
how important is it to be honest
yourself with yourself I'm talking about
past relationships and have you ever
lied to yourself
um
obviously like we said it is really
honest and really honest I'm like
important the drink the Sprite oh God
no listen it is really honest really
honest it's really oh my goodness it's
really important to be honest with
yourself it's because at the end of the
day you're gonna be stuck with yourself
for life so you really you need to know
yourself inside and out yeah there's
really people in this world that
actually believe their own lies so yeah
oh yeah I know someone that believes her
oh
go ahead guys it's a story this is this
one's deep but she never believes that
she's in well she sometimes believes
that and she's in the wrong but you have
to be on like a like a calm level in
order for her to see that and it's
really hard because she she's like such
a Stern person and such a strong woman
that it's hard no she is
okay if you find out who you are there's
a lot of people like that a lot a lot
yeah some people are stopped yeah she's
really stubborn but
um yeah she so it turns out like it ends
up sometimes in in into her lying to
herself and yeah I don't think that's
great there's a word for that I kind of
like remember that word narcissism
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't know yeah we're on the meaning
of the word don't use it simple
what is what is toxic masculinity
um
I think toxic masculinity
is for I think this question is for
women not for men I think it's actually
and the reason why I'm saying that is
because
actually that that word well those two
words are actually what a lot of girls
nowadays are actually perceiving
themselves to be and I can say I'm
guilty for that definitely what do you
mean as in
a lot of girls do say how they prefer to
take charge and be that independent
woman have like
5K 6K what did they see you guys figures
yeah figures yeah all of that and to be
that I'm that girl you can't you can't
tell me what I shouldn't and what I
should wear type of thing I feel like a
lot of girls nowadays are doing that so
I feel like the whole traditional this
more than this I feel like the modern
times now is
awesome and taking charge being that
mass and a lot of guys will say oh yeah
that's so uh but it's like hmm I wonder
why that it's because you guys something
most of you men just want girls you can
just control who's naive and you're just
nice and sweet he can just take
advantage of because it's easy for you
and it's less work no do you know what I
think you think it's time you think it's
toxically masculine to want a nice and
sweet girl
I did not have to say anything to do
with masculinity at all I was going off
of what she said going after what she
said
she said yeah but she was talking about
toxicity
what I said has got nothing to do with
you they don't twist my words
I think toxic masculinity is something
that's been created by women that
like okay we have feminists yeah but
then we have the extreme feminists and I
think the extreme feminists don't want
equality between men and women they want
to take over and I think toxic
masculinity is like something that
they're throwing at men who just have a
really big ego thank you and they just
you know I mean you have a big ego oh
it's toxic nasty no they're egotistical
and if they're not for you you don't
want to deal with them then don't deal
with them but like yeah I definitely
think it's a phrase created by women
don't you think that men in general have
egos yeah yeah 100 we all have it why
don't you say that men throughout
history have been more successful if
they have big egos yeah like the Kings
the Emperors yes I mean yes and no
yes I know I can agree with that so
explain go ahead so obviously like you
have to have a big ego to like be
successful to an extent but then there's
like being successful and then you're
having the ego but you're also humble
but then there's like really really like
super like egotistical people and you're
just like oh like you can't even you
can't even like have a conversation with
them because they just speak so highly
of themselves almost almost as if
they're like bigger than everyone else
and this goes for men and women because
there's women like this as well but yeah
just people that think that they're so
much better than everyone else but we're
all human and we're all like on the same
level I've just found that people seem
to label things that are just like
masculine traits as toxic yeah so so a
more masculine way of dealing with
problems is to not talk about them we're
a feminine like as women like we want to
talk about our problems men in general
don't and so they'll label things that
are traditionally masculine as toxic
masculinity when it's just how men are
and I think it's kind of similar with
like the ego like I just think men tend
to have egos more than women yeah I do
know a couple guys that are not that
don't act out of their ego that are
really like they enjoy having deep
conversations oh wow so attractive
yourself
my cousin he's no no he's very in tune
with himself he's like an old soul I
always tell him this I always big him up
for that he advises me on everything and
he's just amazing
um
so I'm I'm curious do you guys want to
be married at all yes yes yes I mean I
would like to be married but it's not
something that I'm like super set on
like I have to get married in this
lifetime if it happens it happens but I
don't think
I don't think neces I necessarily need
like a piece of paper to prove like my
relationship with someone I don't know
but my parents weren't married so but
they was together for 17 years
um so you would be okay would you want a
long-term relationship then instead of
marriage
um I wouldn't mind obviously if I was in
a long-term relationship and I really
love the person they proposed to me I
would say yeah but I wouldn't mind
whether we like had got married or not
so do you want kids I do okay and you'd
be okay with that in or out of marriage
yeah I'll be fine with that okay
um what about you do you want to go
there truthfully I've never actually
thought about marriage like that but
every time for what I have seen on
social media it has given me like a
pull-off right yeah but
as I said I've never thought about
marriage but back when I was little
Mario was a normal thing but now that
I'm older marriage ain't a thing like
that because divorce is more of a thing
that marriage should that that is the
reason why it's put me off but at the
same time it's like hmm I do want to get
mine but as she just said a paper don't
mean anything so it's like yeah I'm
still thinking on that one and the voice
memes are expensive you know it's
expensive to divorce someone you know
for a good month
[Laughter]
if we're meant to be women to be no
piece of paper should Define it yeah
yeah so it's like you guys as long as we
have like an amazing connection marriage
doesn't mean anything okay what about
you do you want to be married you know
what I always juggle this topic all the
time sometimes I'm like yes like I love
to be all like loved up but other days
no no you know what it is I don't need a
title I feel like we don't need marriage
to obviously like
um
you know I mean say oh yeah my husband
I'm your wife like I feel like we don't
it's like I say I want I think I'm going
off more of the concert like I want to
be loved up and I always I always date
and like relationship wise I'm a
long-term goal you know so I always
that's always like my intention like I'm
quite
um loyal actually
so yeah I don't know what else I think I
love the whole but I do love the whole
black um proposal if you see my viral
proposal thing and McDonald's stuff
I was mad that was mad that was a prank
by the way I'm not getting married but
again I do love the whole like proposal
like aspect did you do a fake proposal I
don't actually oh no we did it blew up
massively that massively like literally
had a 35 million views on that three
days crazy I'll show you after yeah but
basically
um I do like the whole like the
beautiful like proposal thing on like
the rooftop balcony and like the flowers
and I don't know the wedding I think
I'll make a really beautiful bride so so
you you want the the proposal and the
wedding but you're not too sure about
marriage I'm not sure about the guy
about the guy the guy is well what if
you pick a good guy
and if he wants that and it happens
naturally yeah
you know what I mean like it's got you
know it will happen naturally I don't
believe it should be forced and you
can't plan these things and their
relationships is a tricky one it should
happen naturally and like I said should
flow you know so yeah what do you guys
think that you need to bring to the
table in order to be a long-term 20-year
girlfriend or wife and is there a
difference
um I think
stability
if you know you're stable within
yourself mentally financially
every Lee then then I feel like that's
all that matters and likewise for the
man if he's stable enough to be in a
relationship and to accommodate that
financially mentally physically whatever
way emotionally then that's that's what
so do you mean when you say stability
like financially stable yeah as a girl
you should be financially stable okay
don't don't just append everything on
the man you know don't expect because
when you expect things you could let get
let get let down sorry
I agree with that okay yeah go ahead
definitely in a relationship
um you also need to have your own funds
behind you you can't rely on a man
because then what happens if that man
leaves then if you're left with nothing
men don't leave
they always come back that's true no no
fun fact one percent of the time do you
think that women divorce or that men
divorce women I think a lot of the time
it is women that leave a thousand
percent what percent of the time do you
think women leave
maybe like 80 of the time yeah that's
true I think they're just when they're
over there 70 to 80 yeah and what
percent if you're college educated
there's only a 10 chance you're gonna
get left yeah I do think as well like a
stable stable relationship you know
bringing stuff to the table I think you
need to just like have have your
priorities in check you know again like
be stable financially physically
um and be healthy and cheap yeah so fat
people shouldn't find Love Of course
they should they should
definitely
most definitely
so so you don't have to be in shape you
don't have to be in shape
as well as wealth you know if someone is
like really severely overweight and
there's still that has to severely
overweight people when they're in love
and like they don't they don't do
anything about their health how long are
they going to live for oh my God
yeah
my dad told me not to date fat people
because he said you have to take care of
them later
you're gonna live different
90 you want to be yeah you want to be
yeah
a serious issue so you should be in
shape you should bring that it's okay
that's okay
you know you know what it's important to
care for yourself and look after
yourself you know a lot of the time like
when people are like really severely
overweight and like obese and stuff it's
because they're not looking after
themselves
okay
yeah but like yeah
that's okay we hate we hate phobia here
yeah we don't stand for a fat phobia at
all yeah like I'm not against fat people
I used to be fat guys but at the same
time like I'm afraid I'm afraid of fat
people really yeah I'm scared of them is
that phobic what
I'm afraid of them
terrified Jeff night man yeah I'm like
ah
hey I'm prep I'm yeah I'm like
transphobic too I'm all the focused
did not know that existed yeah yeah um
if you call someone fat they'll actually
be like oh yeah
it's not no it's not like I think the
whole body positivity movement is really
important but at the same time if you're
severely overweight people like it's
your health and the other thing that
normalizes obesity I think it does I
think it does and it's not it's not a
good thing because your lifespan is
going to be shortened because you you
don't look after yourself some people
are overweight because of health
conditions and like certain medications
and stuff but that is a very small
minority of people so
um back to the we need stability and
In-Shape anything else Financial
stability stability I think stability
also mentally is really important
obviously you can go through blips of
your mental health like during a
relationship and your partner should
support you vice versa but um yeah to be
in like a healthy relationship I think
like your mental health is something
that you need to prioritize
um anything what should women bring to
the team
[Music]
what should women bring to the table
themselves because every woman is
different so you should know in general
in general yeah in general
your true self of who you really are
exactly
that's true but if you're a loser yeah
what is your definition of a loser
coming back to what I'm about to say Do
not compare me to the next woman or the
woman coming after me because I am
different there's only one you yeah so I
should be bringing myself I have to
offer so throughout my 22 years okay so
what do you have to offer from your 22
years that's a lot we're gonna be here
all day so we'll come back to that
just give me three cool three things
knowledge wisdom and understanding
period done
[Laughter]
go ahead you know what same here like I
said I bring a little table but I'm
gonna be a bit more specific
very important okay a freakiness all
right I would say but yeah no um it
would actually been serious obviously
yeah I'm serious about that but my
Russian being serious
um it would be
um my mindset I think I've got a really
like good elevated type of mindset and I
think that what do you what do you mean
by Alex no elevating anyone has a lot of
kids like motivation like my energy that
I'm quite I have like a good drive and a
motivation I'm quite positive optimistic
so the people around me and in my circle
can feed off my energy and they can all
win in life that's what I'm okay so you
have high energy and you're driven
that's what I mean by like okay my
t-shirt okay yeah I'm just I'm trying to
write this down okay yeah it's really
anything else I would say
um
I'm good at everything
women of many talents
okay
can we can we name one okay
um
oh obviously we want to know I can sing
dance act sing dance act um um I'm smart
as well I'm good at balancing stuff I'm
not balanced up on my head I mean
multitasking yeah multitasking I can
balance a lot I can't do that
yeah okay for example I'll take example
for a long time obviously when I was I
was 19 so obviously last year I just
finished sixth form but throughout my I
started talking music when I was like 16
actually that's not the reason I was 16
17 18 but throughout that process I was
still in full-time education so it was
hard to obviously balance like I'll do
like a sold out show with like and have
like my manager and like see business
and then I have to be dragged onto like
a table and being told it was hard
balancing what all I wanted to do was
fly so again balancing is important and
I still get the Grays I want it by the
end of it
yes okay
we'll give you okay okay so I'm just
gonna read back to what what you guys
said if there's anything you think that
there should be added just let me know
uh being financially stable in shape
mentally stable
um I wrote themselves like knowing
yourself I think that was what I wrote
okay knowledge oh oh that was you you
bring yourself
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness
um
driven high energy singing dancing
acting and multitasking you
talents and it's also you need to be
secure on yourself as well you need to
love yourself that's the most important
thing
security self-love that's the most
important thing okay yeah okay can I add
something
um this is just my personal opinion by
the way I feel like having a source like
my my source is God my source is
spirituality my source is my intuition
so as long as you have a source then
that would yeah add to
so
stability Financial stability in shape
mentally stable bringing yourself
um knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing acting multitasking spirituality
my question my question what my question
was what do you think that we women need
to bring to the table in order to be
aware does this sound like a traditional
wife to you
anything I just read back to you does
that sound like a traditional way I
think maybe like a textbook
old-fashioned wife would be like you
know
um I think nurturing caring you know can
raise children can cook and clean
typical like wife like back in the day
caring so so why didn't we name any of
those things before because I think we
were kind of I don't know we already
know that point I was kind of balancing
like both men and women
listen all honesty like the stuff you
guys listed sounds like what women would
want from a guy
women and men aren't the same we don't
look for the same things like women men
don't want dudes I'm blessing you want
to date a girl that acts like a dude
yeah but the reason why the reason why I
did mention too
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna test
something I've done this before it's not
just you guys last thing would you want
to date a girl does this like sound like
wife material financially stable in
shape got in shape that's good mentally
stable
um them bringing themselves to the table
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing good at multitasking spiritual
secure and self-love that's the whole
package is there is there anything more
but you know what I was looking anyway
guys
some of that stuff but the majority but
in particular sorry I'm curious yeah
what did you like from that list
um I like the freakiness
what's up with you guys
[Laughter]
we actually look for like wifey material
like nurturing
um yeah we don't need you to bring
anything to the table really to be
honest um so you go with anyone then
yeah he's not trim yeah yeah being
themselves like he's going for a girl oh
yeah
themselves honest yeah in themselves um
now some of this stuff is a bit
pretentious like you think so yeah you
think spirituality is pretentious
depends what what kind of spirituality
is it actually you know what yeah I need
to hear your answer properly you guys
let's let him speak
yeah I think she's a point of
spirituality what what spiritually is it
well it depends for me I believe that
all everything is down to one so I
believe every God that they serve and
every religion is one God yeah that's
something to say I believe that division
is I don't know why there's division in
in religion but that's that's up to them
yeah but I feel like everything all
stems from or should stem from love
right love love is what war oh yeah so
would you date someone from any religion
then you would say yes I actually would
depending on their mindset and how they
perceive their religion and how they
believed like how they understand their
religion it's all mindset it is months
and yeah I would how would that work in
your household
um as long as we can compromise and you
know make sure that all the good aspects
of the religion are being applied into
our relationship
then do you believe men men are the
leaders of the relationship yes I do so
if they say that my children are
Christian or they're Muslim are you
gonna go with that I'm gonna be fine
with it my mom was a Christian my dad's
a Muslim so I was brought up in a very
diverse religion I guess I don't know
but I came out to be spiritual you can
say submission is what we're looking for
he was looking for submission you you
are submissive woman because I feel like
a man wants to feel like a man
he wants to feel like a man so if
there's a woman and like she's wearing
the pants and she's taking complete
control he's not gonna feel very manly I
have a question if a guy said to you
take that off that's too revealing Are
You Gonna Change are you gonna argue
[Music]
and try to understand depending on the
occasion on why you're telling me to
take it off because if I'm going for a
girls night out why can't I skin out and
I would argue a little bit because yeah
a little bit of jealousy as well so I
would argue but then um I'll still go
out in the same outfit too bad
do you think that makes all of you toxic
yeah because you just said you'd be okay
with submission but when he told you
what to do you're gonna argue I mean
when it comes to telling someone what to
do like telling me I can't wear a
certain outfit because it's too
revealing like
I want to protect you it's like but the
thing is is he protecting me from other
men or is he insecure and not
comfortable with me going out because
other men are gonna look at me if you
have a nice car
I mean are you going to put a for sale
sign on it are you going to advertise
what is submission to you guys
I think submission is just being a
feminine woman like I really like in a
man yeah when he can like not take
control of me but take control of
certain situations so like say if we
like plan to go somewhere he planned it
or he can like make decisions for
himself but also for the both of us but
like within reason like certain
decisions that need to be communicated
between like both Partners yeah but like
yeah
that is no submission okay
I think submission is when
um the female is very much in her well
sometimes what she said but let's do
that's the guy that kind of um
so for you guys our mission is a bit
more sexual I didn't get to answer that
but submission is um abiding by the
rules of your um opposite sex so what
when he says oh yeah don't wear that
you're literally saying
something like yes sir I'm not gonna do
it because you have your reasons to why
I'm not even questioning it because but
you guys just see it right now that you
will not do it I mean it depends like if
you're wearing a dress and you're like
your nipples are happening I'm just
answering your questions
that if it's like a little mini dress
and you're going to the club of your
girls then I don't see why it should be
an issue but then like if it's like
something super like your ass cheeks are
hanging out your nipples are popping out
and everything
as a man is gonna is there to lead his
family he has a vision for his family so
if he says in my family in my household
if we don't wear that you're supposed to
be like okay yeah but if you guys are
what you're saying is no uh there's some
things you can decide but you say
something no I said I said I'm a
Christian occasion I understand the
reason why I mean there's always
compromise so what do you think being
submissive actually is then it's
actually only one definition
once you submit you should actually just
trust him you can't even question it
that's what we expect what does submit
mean to you because I thought we stated
it I feel like I feel like that stems of
tradition guys the definition the death
wait the definition is the action of
accepting or yielding to a superior
force or to the will or authority of
another person so abiding by his rules
so I'm gonna decide whether or not if I
should abide by his rules
and women should actually be equal but
obviously let them make some of the
decisions I guess it's about about
balance you can't just say oh I'm gonna
oh he's a superior worship him
take him into account um I don't know
how old you are but like if you're an
older guy you're gonna have slightly
different like values like as a 20 year
old 22 year old sorry
we want to go out and like have fun you
know we'll wear our little tight dress
[Laughter]
the way you were raised up what do you
has 100 what do you think works modern
dating or old-fashioned dating
old-fashioned I personally I like
old-fashioned okay
wait wait wait let me stop you let me
stop you how how do you expect
old-fashioned outcomes in traditional
courting and traditional outcomes if you
don't want to act like a traditional
women in traditional women submit I
don't know do I no
if it works it works no but it's like
I'll say for example like obviously like
an older woman she's not really like
she's going to dress a bit more maturely
you're like she's going to be more
modest and stuff I feel like in today's
generation yeah when we're young we
always want to be skin out and like wear
these little booty shorts why not look
at me right now if you've got it show it
off yeah but that's the mindset of like
the modern day generation like back in
the day like the housewives without
going to the club and that is looking
out and stuff like that you're not going
to get more modest I will say that
you're not gonna get like a you say
traditional outcome yeah of course it
clashes with the new like you don't know
of course it is because you guys even
when you're saying oh I'll question him
and ask him about the if your boss gives
you an order at work you can't and your
boss says hey this is the uniform do you
question him so why do we question like
why do we question we not question our
bosses but we're going to question the
person that we want to make a family
with I do questions
why do I need to and I'm sure you're his
favorite employer I actually am because
I'm honest I feel like that all depends
on the title you give him as in you can
actually make your own definition of
what a boyfriend or a friend or family
or Mom or Dad could be
it all depends on the title that you
give them all depends on how you see
them as in you can make your own rules
as you go
[Music]
if you want to lead the relationship
sure but like do women typically end up
happy when they're making the decisions
and making the rules and leading the
relationship because we allow our
emotions so so it's kind of like you
guys are saying you want your cake and
you also want to eat it too
um
[Laughter]
I could juggle both thing is I'm not
making the rules and follow how do you
lead and follow at the same time
compromisation yeah so do you want every
every single decision you guys have a
conversation about yeah like you said
every single does that seem like an
efficient way to do things marriages
aren't going to be perfect the same way
being boyfriend girlfriend ain't gonna
be perfect so it's like that is leading
up to it that's the whole I'm not I'm
not saying it's going to be perfect but
at the end of the day when you guys
disagree someone has to make a decision
and there's always somebody someone has
to give right and it's always going to
be someone he's gonna give there's
always going to be an end who should and
and typically what I see nowadays is is
the man gives more he gives up more and
then we say the woman wears the pants in
the relationship no I agree with that
and so but the woman usually hates the
man when she's in a relationship where
she has to wear the pants
in general women that are ball busters
that wear
you know you you're thinking of someone
I can see it in your face like the ones
that make all the decisions in the
relationship that are wet their
boyfriends whipped they hate their
boyfriends yeah they shouldn't even be
in a relationship in the first but they
need to go fix it that's what I'm saying
the mentality the mentality you guys
have that's where you're going yeah no
do you know what though I feel like when
you really love a man and you fall into
it you naturally do become
[Laughter]
fall in love with someone and you get
into a relationship with them you do
naturally as a woman become more
submissive I don't know like yeah for
every woman that's the same with me that
because
feminine side right yeah you become more
feminine it's only natural
do you think that men are feminine until
they meet the right woman no so I
thought I become feminine afterwards
after they meet the right women because
you're with the women all day and you
are who you're surrounded by actually
going back to what you said I feel like
the only reason why a woman put up that
old toxic masculinity is by them
protecting themselves so they don't get
hurt yeah I agree with that that's true
it's a protection time yeah explain that
again so people um girls act bad and the
reason why they act like a guy is is
because
they're literally protecting themselves
I don't know how else to like yeah
because they don't want to feel that
hurt again yeah
that goes to the concept it's like
you're making the men of the future pay
for the mistakes of your past yeah if
you carry it with you yeah if you're
acting like a dude so you don't get hurt
I mean like how many times do guys act
like girls so they don't get hurt
said it
um experience of relationship to shape
who you are who are meant to become so
when you meet the right person you're
not going to be able to fall into the
same track
that's why yeah yeah
I mean there's a difference between
being naive and being traumatized
so so it's one thing if you're naive
right you can I can understand that
maybe not being so naive but it's a
different thing when you're bringing
your trauma into your yeah I don't like
the word trauma I don't like the word
trauma
nonsense your rough relationship
experience with your baggage yeah your
baggage into your future but it's like
you know how how do we move forward with
men and like actually get together and
get along with them if we don't trust
them well I think again like if you have
a lot of baggage that self-reflection
and self-heating that you have to do in
order for you to be in a situation
because if you get into a relationship
and you have a [__] ton of baggage and
then you're pushing all of that baggage
onto that person who wants a
relationship with you and now they're
carrying your baggage as well as you it
becomes an unhealthy environment what
does healing look like I think no one's
fully healed okay but I think I think
through life everyone is healing
constantly constantly things are going
on in life and people heal from things
every single day you're never fully
healed like there's no definition of
being oh I'm Healed like I'm a healed
person yeah but if you wanted to take
steps to heal I would definitely look at
self-reflection self-reflection see the
things that have triggered me or things
that have caused me issues in the past
and how can I grow from that and how can
I work towards improving them so these
triggers don't affect me anymore and I
don't bring this baggage into future
relationships or push my own
insecurities and issues onto other
people because of my past experiences
what about therapy therapy is good but
therapy only works if you're willing to
do therapy if you go to therapy and you
don't want to do therapy then it's not
going to work for you I've just I've
done a lot of these shows and I just
found when girls say self-reflection
it's like nothing it's like listen to
some read some books put on some candles
listen to something I think
self-reflection I think journaling is
really important to write down how you
feel so then you can look back on it and
reflect on it and be like okay I felt
like this way yeah this is what I did I
might have acted out of character or
done this because again like looking
inwards is difficult it's difficult to
realize
and you see it from another perspective
almost yeah you're reading the story but
it's your story yeah I mean I also feel
like allow yourself to go through
whatever has hurt you in the past yeah
you have to face the most painful thing
you could ever do allow yourself to go
through that again feel those emotions
that you felt when you went through that
you know so then you could reflect from
it Grow from it and acknowledge it and
see it like how much you've changed
because I'm sure you must have grown
from that moment as well so it's nice to
sometimes look back and think all my
days I used to be like this but now I'm
like this so again journaling in asper
is good yeah to overcome uh blessing did
you have any more questions about
submission for them I feel like you had
another one but I'm going to cut you off
yeah now I'm just gonna conclude and say
that we look for submission because
submission brings peace and if you guys
are not gonna submit to us we're not
gonna have peace and then one piece and
if he's snoring he's snoring
understandable submission but what if
what if your wife for example feels like
what you're saying doesn't really align
with what she believes to be right or
true do you feel like that's her going
against you or that's her well for me
personally I would question it I'd be
like okay so why I wouldn't necessarily
want to have an argument I wouldn't
necessarily want to go against what
you're saying I just want to understand
from your perspective how has that
favored you in the past
um that that means that you're not
compatible that means you don't have the
same vision and you're not aligned I'm a
Christian and and as a Christian there's
a story in the Bible about Abraham who
basically had a conversation with God
and he told him to just go
and that was just between him and God
and he had to take his wife his wife
didn't know where he was going and she
just followed that submission she
trusted her yeah trust and bring
submission so if you don't have that
that means you just maybe just you're
just not compatible
okay I actually agree with that
okay I do to an extent
what's your name again blessing you have
you're truly a blessing moral surely a
blessing at the end of the day I think
the main goal for a lot of people is
just peace you don't want arguments you
don't want toxicity exactly if you know
exactly yeah didn't we start the show
and like we said you like toxicity
I have changed so much about this
podcast literally
right I've come from you know whatever
Us in the past now actually yeah sorry
to be the the person but you can have
peace and someone can stay cheap behind
your back and just make it seem as if
yeah it's normal as long as I move you
yeah because you know you won't let it
affect you because you don't want to eat
pizza there's different scenarios you
can be at peace but the guys still doing
stuff that you shouldn't be doing and
you're just being submissive you get it
so it's like yeah but it could go the
other way around too I mean like he
could like she could be doing stuff that
she's not supposed to be doing well but
like it's like as women we're always
bringing up the worst case scenarios
it's like what could go wrong instead of
what could go right I agree with that
100 I think we have a very very negative
mindset when we get into relationships a
lot of people like oh what if he cheats
on me what if he does this or he's
sneaky
because of like what Society reveals to
us and you think that they make men to
be these villains I think social media
social media there's a reason there's a
reason why we think like this we don't
just think like this like that out of
nowhere but you know what I think it
depends what kind of content you consume
on social media okay the popular culture
yeah is very very toxic like constantly
like people couples arguing people get
influenced by it right you're saying if
you don't watch that if you don't watch
that then you're not going to get
influenced by it like social media is a
platform yeah and you can choose what
like what you want to absorb and what
you don't but what you absorb it does
have an effect on you whether you think
it or not like subconsciously it does
affect you I definitely know I consume
some really bad stuff and you also
control what you double tap and follow
it
I have a question I have a question all
right based on this conversation who on
the piano out of the four of you would
you want to set your brother up with
starting to go around I would want to
yeah
yeah okay based on like what we've said
about relationships sorry go ahead
um
yeah probably you you know you're very
spiritual like you're free spirit like I
love that go ahead who would you set
your brother up with
um because I don't know if you don't get
a brother just pick cousin a good one a
good one not
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay we'll do cousin
so I was gonna say you as well do you
know what you know why do you know why I
have a reason actually because I feel
like
similar morals I feel like you're very
chill as piece already there does that
make sense there's no you have to do the
overthink it sometimes you just gotta be
calm no no no I mean that just
I mean genuine
not too not much going on that makes
sense okay yeah I'm gonna take a second
to read who would you set your brother
up oh yeah
I'll tell you why spirituality not this
weird stuff I need you to pick a
religion or just uh
she's the following I don't need my
brother
she's not you guys both said you
wouldn't listen
[Music]
I don't know what it is you you got the
the nose ring I just don't like nose
rings
you cannot no you're just judging yeah
I'm judged off of what you've brought to
the show
and yeah yeah you can't judge based on
periods like everyone has those things
literally everyone has everyone everyone
okay she has a nose piece okay okay okay
I come from so I come from a one percent
family okay I come from a lot of men
that a lot of like women would want a
date I grew up around like the top one
percent men in society that make
millions of dollars and I can tell you
absolutely men judge you by the way you
dress and by the way you carry yourself
so so yeah yeah so when you're wearing
[__] clothes they'll judge you when
you're wearing piercings they judge you
when they wear a ton of makeup they
judge you and so I could lie to you and
say oh they don't care but they do care
which is fine but if you if you want to
be alone that's fine but if you want to
be a lot like
if you're trying to sell a car why would
you not want to understand the buyer
so so anything like if you want to be
alone fine that's that's totally fine
but realistically before anything men
always look at how you look oh yeah
they're not gonna if they're not
physically attracted to you then they're
not going to come and approach you and
yeah and it's the same for women as well
yeah yeah yeah like it might not you
might have like oh like I go for
personality but like looks is always
there yeah 100 it is and we judge them
based on you know their income like
you're not I mean you guys are young you
guys are you guys are young so it might
be ambition or driven but I mean I'm
sure when I when I was your age it was
like is he in sports is he doing
something in the school so he has to be
doing something right and later that's
going to translate to income
um you know women judge them on their
height
women judge them based on how they dress
like if they dress like what do they say
a lame that's what the kids say lame
boring
[Music]
um I'm gonna give you the super chats
though for a second
um guys sign up for our email list um I
know I've said this so many times a show
okay well we got a really cool Community
going on at Jess pearly things all right
we are going to be doing parties in
different cities we're going to do
meetups in different cities I'm even
thinking about matchmaking for like
traditionally minded people but I have
to build an email list I have to build a
base of people that want to be a part of
it we're also going to sell um beautiful
Majestic creature merch
but I can't sell it on YouTube because I
might get kicked off so sign up for the
email list
um also guys make sure you like the
video at a thousand likes we are going
to open up the chat and that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams so
Soros lost what if society called you
stupid weak and small for wanting a man
making more money taller confident
ambitious leaders stop shaming men for
our standards Chief Keef fomo of high
lifestyle lives are generally miserable
the UK Economist please ask your guests
what they why they think they deserve
traditional men if they aren't
traditional virgins black Moses thank
you Pearl for showing us women what
women to avoid none of them mentioned
peace they are all side chicks fellas
invest in cat food and blocks wine I'm
90 Frito pie it takes four women to
answer one question
um poppy her dress is so little she has
to cross her legs Zoro sloth most people
most of the women
after I'm done reading please find them
after I'm done okay so
Zoro is Zorro most of the panel is a
prime example of why 50 percent of women
will be single and childless by 2030 not
being a hoe Being Fit feminine friendly
and compliant is what keeps a man 90
Frito pie women want lions with no teeth
or claws they want danger supervised a
redo button convenience blank they made
a whole list of expectations but we just
want peace we don't want to come home
from a stressful job to more stress afro
so
um it seems like a younger version of
Esther I'm completely delusional and
toxic but doesn't see any of it in
herself um invest in chewy 90 Frito pie
have any of these girls had an honest
convo with their parents about marriage
girls would be happier if they didn't
care about women's opinions solo girl
needs to match her foundation zoro's the
panel is side chick material VJ Ms
everyone has lied to themselves you are
ultimately responsible for who you
choose to get into a relationship with
you allow the other person to crawl to
control your life um these girls are so
cute
they're insecure because at the end of
the day
like it the rest of you are just trying
rubbish I can't handle the Badness on
camera that's your problem
I'm gonna refresh this word for that
have you guys ever had a conversation
with your parents about marriage no
but yeah yeah what'd they tell you oh my
I mean my mom has been married once she
wasn't married to my dad actually
um but she had three kids from him so
that automatically showed me that you
don't have to be married in order to
build a life right
um are they still together no
okay no they're not and my mom
ultimately doesn't really believe in
love at the moment oh wow it's like yeah
so you really didn't have like an
example to look up to well what I was
like who do you who do you go to about
relationship questions
um
who won not really I don't really I
don't really
um
talk to I'm very like to myself I keep
to myself because I feel like that's
where I find my piece and
um I feel like not everybody can relate
to my mindset
so I don't
necessarily go to anyone to I don't know
yeah I guess that makes sense
um my parents I grew up in quite a toxic
household so I wouldn't say that I've
gone to my parents for any relationship
marriage advice but my friends my best
friend's parents have been married for
20 plus years and I really look up to
their marriage I see how they are with
each other and it also showed me what to
like accept and like my like what I
expect from a relationship kind of like
I don't know like when you see like a a
successful like marriage and a
successful relationship it kind of is
okay like I strive to have that in the
future
have you ever asked them about how they
stayed married and like what advice they
would have for you communication is that
what they said yeah communication is so
important okay what about you never
um where do I go for advice I thought
for relationship with us I don't go
anywhere for relationship advice I never
actually thought about doing such thing
actually are your parents still married
yeah yeah they are what do you think
they would say does your mom listen to
your dad
for the most part yeah yeah so you think
that might be a good way to go about it
yeah it has its ups and downs coming
from an African household so I can't
really like touching that too tough
where are your parents from Nigeria
Nigeria yeah
what are what are some of the cons of
submission
not having your own mind and somewhat
being manipulative
you you think that
um women are manipulated they're
manipulated yeah yeah
how so
being controlled she's right yeah
there's a potential for that yeah like
they have their own mind they know what
is right they know what is good but just
because that's what the man wants that's
what's gonna go because of what they've
said even though within them they know
no
when did your mind start to because I'd
imagine it wasn't your whole life that
you thought this way
no no so when when did you start to
think that was bad
um
properly
last year when I realized there and
you're 22 Yeah 22 so I run 21. in school
right yeah yeah and when I started
realizing it
was when I was
like 14 15 okay yeah
who do you think has better outcomes
traditional relationships or modern
that's a hard one because the reason why
I said that because it all stems from
culture as well so it's like it all
depends like for example Muslims and
Christians you can't really like put
them in the same
conversation because there's times when
they have arranged marriages and they
have to go with what their family says
or what the husband says and they're not
allowed to have like maybe like
businesses of their own is that right is
that wrong
I don't I don't think that I think a lot
of them work in like family businesses
yeah but I'm talking about having their
own businesses do women don't want to
work with do women typically want their
own businesses I haven't typically go to
business yes yes there's a lot of
successful no but black and white women
who are having successful businesses but
you know what I'll actually like stop
you there for a second because like I
think it's modern day society that has
pushed women to want their own
businesses and to become like CEOs and
stuff because traditionally a lot of
women like they stay at home the man is
the breadwinner you know they look after
the kids they they do whatever they do
but like modern day Society has said
like oh women should be bosses too and
women should go for this I think there
is difference
can be a business
but there is that added pressure with
the media there are definitely yeah
it's not it's not a bad or a bad thing I
guess it just kind of depends
so that goes back to when rumor didn't
have the right to vote is that I think
we should go back to that I decided that
yeah is that good or bad like you're
good it's good yeah it's good yeah yeah
so it's a good thing okay cool thank you
yeah I'm done
I think that women are bad at business
the certain aspects depending on what it
is you can't say no they're not good at
hair
I think that men make more logical
decisions and women make a lot of
decisions based off emotion yeah no
because the men have had more time yeah
because we do know we do know that
females are more emotionally wired than
men yeah 100 100 and I do feel like
women make a lot of decisions based off
emotion a lot of the time
and that's why that's why they may not
necessarily be as good as [__] an
argument I literally like if I'm dating
someone like getting a an argument I'm
really heated I literally have to give
myself like a three hour four hour break
just to like control my emotions then go
back on it on a calm head because I
would say some rush things out of
emotion like I said emotion is you know
women ask female is all about like the
female emotions and men just don't
really care you know what I just looked
up I was just curious I found her I just
did the first big Beauty brand I could
think of L'Oreal who founded it a guy
[Music]
women I just don't think women manage
people well and to get a really really
big business business is about money
um and men are all about their money
their income and they're all about the
numbers they don't care about feeling
they care about emotions which is good
which is which is good in business which
is why yeah like which is why they're
very driven in okay Money numbers like
pretty little things going bad guy I
know it is it is and they're all about
you know driving that and they'll and
they get rid of people that like are bad
immediately yeah where it's like women
we're like oh
and I say this I
was like all about good customer service
yeah I say this as someone that's like
doing it I'm like 90 of women couldn't
do what I do and I don't and I couldn't
do it without men like I could I
couldn't if I didn't have the structure
of guys around like I couldn't do it 100
even with me when I film my music videos
and doing all these shows and tours or
whatever like a lot of them are men
actually that's the reason why a lot of
women yeah that's reason why a lot of
women go to men for advice because
they're not like
what's that word they're just logical
they're just straight up yeah yeah yeah
and also like to be a CEO or like an
owner of a business you have to be
ruthless like you actually be ruthless
like not a lot of women have that in
them to have that Stern like control
do you know what phrase I think is
reversed when they say behind every
successful man is a successful woman I
think it's the other way around behind
every successful woman is a successful
man I agree because if you look at even
like pop stars like a lot of times
there's always a mentorism there's
someone mentoring them that is so true
yeah that is true and if you look at it
I think like you might say your personal
experiences yeah I look up to like a lot
of guys who were like big in the music
I'm close with and who are like famous
famous and I've learned a lot like so
much even even yeah
I talked to her I talked to someone in
the freaking
um I forgot who someone that worked in
the music industry and they said the
reason that record labels are like
slowed fine girls is because they'll
meet a boy and then just
yeah they get into a relationship and
they just forget about everything else
again like they make their relationship
their whole life and then we keep saying
about how you need to love yourself and
have con self-control boundaries and
like yeah don't just drop everything for
this I think I mean it depends what
outcome you want yeah so it depends if
if you want to make a bunch of money and
that's your number one priority then
sure but I mean I know girls that want
13 kids yeah so how old do you wanna how
old so for a girl that wants 13 kids
what's the best what's the best outcome
for her oh there's a guy that'll pay the
bills he wants a lot of kids
drop everything so that's why they'll
stay as long as it works because it's
what they want that's why that's why so
the girls like oftentimes if you see
like the girls that say don't drop
everything you know they don't usually
have better outcome and the girls that
do
foreign
I mean when it comes to relationships
yeah well I would say as well though
like behind every like that phrase
behind every man there is a successful
woman I wouldn't necessarily say like
successful in like the financial like
sector or something but a woman that's
supportive and pushes him to do better
like maybe she's there to help him
emotionally like he comes home and he's
been working a really long day and he
knows that he's going to come on to a
cooked meal and he's gonna come home to
love and support no matter no matter
what I think that's really motivating
for him I want a name I'm gonna name
three billionaires Bill Gates Jeff Bezos
Elon Musk
divorce divorce single
yes he's single
man
he's got like he's got like six baby
mama yeah
he's a Jamaican oh he reads them he's a
Jamaican
Jamaican guys they breed anything no
literally
don't forget the Nigerian demon you hear
about demons
um but yeah dumb okay
one second guys thank you so much for
the super chats we are really helping
build the community at just pearly
things
um
also um like the video and sign up for
our email list guys the email list is
going to be events it's going to be
matchmaking we're going to do merch
we're going to build this whole
Community this year of events in
different cities it's going to be a lot
of fun
um I think we're gonna do the first one
uh this month in central London
um probably just on like a Sunday or
something else follow me on Twitter
pearly things with a z and sign up for
our email list to be notified okay
um so wait wait I'm refreshing it one
second guys
okay um Evan show us the notebook Pearl
um tsunami I'm willing to catch I'm
willing to fight catch me at UFC 286
380. because I said I was gonna fight
them
by the way my
name I love you Pearl uh Nicholas uh
thank you for the soup is that is that
50 in the US 50 Super Chat
um Evan uh Pearl isn't writing anything
down show us the notebook Pro I
love it
[Music]
petty petty King in the in the words of
Myron recreational use only the gem um
smashable not wifeable Isaac if I'm if
I'm choosing the mother of my child I'm
not looking for a 304 and none of these
women are wife material I'm 90 Frito pie
I said you can't handle it that's why
I said
I said I said one of the one of the
rules is to not interrupt me till I'm
done with the super chats that's one of
the rules we read before the shows did
you hear that guys I'm getting total fat
now please open in the comments that's
no but you pause and no no no no
it's to wait till I'm done with the
Super Chat it's two okay
um you need to go go okay you can't be
this rude go go I'll sign go on go go
come on go
you're gonna kick me off yeah go go
[Laughter]
I'm not even have me on the show oh my
goodness
is it am I going now I need to leave
anywhere I can't even lie
see you later guys follow me everywhere
it's pretty official you know the vibes
okay zero follow how will you keep the
average man from walking away you don't
see it now but slowly men are leaving
relationships and marriage to Western
women if you can't change this the US
and the UK will fall Evan the best
advice to women is to try to get a guy
that makes six figures is to wait until
they're 40 and triple their body count
in the meantime
um
uh keep up the good work and picking
apart the BS your future husband is is
in Pennsylvania azuro slot 11 what if
society called you stupid weak and small
for wanting a man making more money
taller confident ambitious leader stop
shaming men for our standards uh Chief
keep fomo of high style lives are
generally miserable the UK Economist
please ask your guests why they think
they deserve traditional men if they
weren't traditional virgins I'm going to
refresh it one more time
um
okay
um why when you write why do you skip
every third word pearl
um tiger ask female Bono who hurt you
okay
um um let me
I'm gonna ask you guys one more question
then we're probably gonna close out the
show
um in your opinion what is the biggest
factor that contributes to the
perpetuation of toxic relationships go
ahead
um does anybody else want to stop I'm
not sure
um lack of communication lack of
communication and understanding because
some people communicate just to like
wait so for people listen yeah just so
they can like get their response across
but like actual communication is like
listening to understand and understand
that person's point of view and also to
also understand the other person's point
of view and then you can come to a
compromise or vice versa but yeah lack
of communication
okay go ahead what do you think I think
um Temptation so having like many
choices
um being distracted
and also lack of communication and no
self-discipline
can you explain that more I don't know
no self-discipline like can I have an
example
like self-control I guess yeah it
relates to that yeah when any sort of in
any sort of like environment like
whether it's like in your work in your
personal life like if you're around a
group of people when they're doing drugs
then you just give in and you're like oh
I'll do it because everyone else is
doing it that's lack of self-control
yeah and then you're easily influenced
good
yeah um self-discipline most definitely
um
who's the first thing you said
you said about
um
no because I do I do believe that like I
it's about it was about
um
communication I believe community and
honest communication being honest about
your feelings is very important so
um yeah that's that's what I think
did you guys learn anything new today
yeah that fact you said about um only 15
of men being over six foot over six foot
I thought it would have been more than
that because you have like there's like
a tribe somewhere in Africa and they're
like the tallest people they're like
they grow like
the name of it but it's just super tall
it's like it's only the men we see
it's okay it's no it's like most girls I
mean you know I anyways go ahead
um I learned that Bill Gates was
divorced you didn't hear that divorced I
didn't know that I thought it was kind
of recent yeah it was recent I don't
really keep up with news I'm more of
like I don't know
the thing pops up so it's like so
negative
I can't watch it it gives me anxiety I
don't want to know if the world's coming
to an end just let me yes
just let me know in peace okay
um two things is the first thing how a
lot of men actually run businesses and
there's less women actually doing so and
the second thing is
is um when you said it's actually a man
that actually keeps
a woman going not a woman keeping a
mango and that's just that was mad when
I actually get to think about that yeah
that's actually really true
yeah sometimes I think women give
themselves too much credit yeah no they
do we no not me they do they do
they actually have a question for you
guys Bill Gates and Elon Musk do you
really think the women deserved half
like they helped him build double the
income
depending on what they helped him build
I mean if they were like really Hands-On
and like really really helping then then
yeah if they were really like 50 50 in
it but if she was just like a housewife
or something then no then no he worked
for all of that why should he give away
half of it
yeah that's that's the thing because a
lot of girls were like oh here she was
there from the beginning I'm like yeah
that's nice but yeah I'm just thinking
if I had a boyfriend now right I
wouldn't expect if I was married now
like would I would I expect him to take
half of the YouTube channel
[Music]
because he was there I'm like I don't
know all they should expect is
recognition and nothing else that's it
um thank you guys for coming
um this was a fun show yes um definitely
we I'm gonna read the last Super chats
and then you guys will have final
thoughts any Instagram whatever you want
to shout out
um okay
um can you call it a lack of
communication when there's no submission
to hear your input in order to even have
a compromise Emmanuel W Pearl she was
annoying
um Sammy the girl should the girls
should have a notebook kick her out 90
Frito pie when you write why do you skip
every third word okay it's because I'll
start writing something and then
there'll be talk it's like awkward you
know but sometimes I just you know I
just need certain notes I remember
certain things
um tiger
ask female Bono Bono who hurt you
uh I don't know what Bono is you guys
don't get it no okay I don't know who
that is
break it down I don't know who that is
really uh
Okay evan
um show us the notebook Pro I did that
makes sense and then wait let me refresh
it really
so I have a question for you pal
um why do you take notes
oh sometimes girls
you guys will it's not just you it's
everyone they'll they'll take they'll
say I just started this a couple shows
ago but it's because when you guys
answer something like a lot of times
girls will do these like winded answers
and it's like by the time they get to
the end of like what they're saying I
don't even remember what they said in
the beginning because they just will
like go on and like so it's kind of like
yeah to remind me what they said
sometimes I'll write down like things
you guys said earlier in the show so I
can like remember if you contradict
yourself later okay do you ever take any
of like what you write down do you ever
like apply certain things that you feel
like would be valid to to you like to
apply to you what do you mean like for
example you like hear like a good point
that you maybe like have not come across
before you apply am I biased yeah of
course
everyone's bad I think it's I think it's
silly to say that you're not biased to
anything yeah
um I've changed my opinion on a lot of
things over the years
um it's an opinion I've changed I I used
to think that marriages could never come
back from cheating I now think they can
um I used to think that I probably when
I heard um a Kevin Samuels video when I
first and like she said her husband
cheated and I was like oh leave his ass
and then but then I heard and I started
to really think about it and I was like
you know at the end of the day you are
putting your feelings of being hurt that
you're cheated on every your family and
is that more important than your
children hmm
I think if you're willing to work
through it I think if it's a constant
thing and it keeps happening and you
keep getting disrespected then that's
like that's different you should leave
them but yeah like if something does
happen
a few years down the line or whatever I
think if you can't work through it that
you should be able to work through it
I'll try at least I think of a relative
of mine as like the ideal wife and she
actually
um I've told the story so many times on
the podcast but she actually she was
with um her husband and they lived in
northern Wisconsin okay and he had a
whole side chick in Chicago okay because
he would go like back and forth for work
whatever and she prayed to God for a
solution and he he left the whole family
for the side chick and she wanted to be
married so bad she wanted her family
together so bad that she prayed to God
please God send us a solution the side
chick died
yeah I mean he came home and they stayed
married yeah twice
and when I think of like that level of
empathy and forgiveness to be able to I
mean uh you know not the death you know
sorry sorry but but it's like I I think
that like the ideal wives will try to
keep their family together no matter
what and in constant in culture today
it's really common for us to say end the
marriage for this or that or your
personal feelings but I think the best
wives will put their feelings aside for
the family 100 especially if you have a
family like obviously if you're really
really unhappy in the relationship and
it's not working then I think you guys
have to go your separate way sometimes
it's too toxic and you have to go your
separate ways for anything to work but
for the sake of your children and stuff
I think it's important to try and work
through things especially if you have
kids if you don't have kids then it's a
bit different but if you have a whole
family and you've built a foundation for
yourself I think it's important to at
least try and work through it and and
what they don't talk about is that one
in four marriages are sexless
so a lot of times girls won't have sex
with their husband for like six months a
year two years three years
um you know one of my I have a friend
who's a 20-year divorce attorney and
like some of the stories he tells me are
so sad and so it's like these guys are
in a situation where if they get
divorced she'll take half their stuff so
they don't really want to do that and
you know they're good Dads they want to
be in the home but their wife isn't
sleeping with them so they're like
they're trapped they're stuck and so
they step out but like what is he
supposed to do she's not sleeping with
him is it going to be celibate forever
and that's the kind of nuance that like
when you know we're kind of taught in
normal culture that we don't talk about
we don't really talk about the men's
side you know I I can think of a lot of
wives that post
pictures on social media for attention
and in a way that's cheating like if
you're posting a butt picture on
Instagram but it's kind of the
equivalent like women attention is to
women like sex is to men and so it's
like
you know it's not as black and white
yeah and that's that's my whole point is
I'm not for cheating I would never you
know I don't think that's right but we
don't ever talk about the men's point of
view and like really understanding where
they're coming from yeah 100 percent
I think as women we're just kind of
stuck in our own like views like oh we
view this but you see this like you have
to accept that or otherwise like I'm
leaving you or this is not okay and why
do we always think that we're right
yeah we do yeah why is that because
we're stubborn I feel like it's because
because of how much emotion we have and
how like intense it feels in that moment
we just feel like you know what this is
the best solution and have you ever
gotten into a fight with a guy and then
he says his point of view and then you
just completely like oh [__] I'm wrong
yes yeah yeah because it's like all the
stuff he's done that you haven't thought
about or taken into yeah yeah and and
you know a lot of times people think I'm
saying I'm different or I'm special I'm
not saying I'm different or special I'm
just trying to convey what what the
men's point of view is yeah and there's
really no one in media doing that like I
feel like women we go our whole lives
without being told men well like my men
like submissive women yeah
that's true
that is very true yeah I agree
awkward
[Laughter]
that is so hard
no comment
um
what is she doing
getting her yeah she didn't come even in
a dress yeah oh I see I see
I was like I thought she was really gone
I didn't realize she was done
there's like a back door but
um okay well thank you guys for coming
thank you feel free to put any Instagram
social media whatever
um go ahead starting here go around so
my Instagram is Shaz on a Vibe
um double z double I my take talk is
Shaz on a Vibe double Zed and yeah
follow me
okay my Instagram is
dania.columbia d-a-n-y-a and then
Colombia with
c-o-l-u not an O but the country
Colombia I think
my Instagram and Tick Tock and Snapchat
and Twitter and all the other social
teams that are out there which I have
missed out is official
official there ain't no other way of
spelling That official MST Marie that is
official m s t movie
thank you
[Laughter]
um okay guys I'm gonna read if there's
any more Super chats before the show
ends
um a couple announcements before we end
the show guys we are a network so it's
just probably things Network that means
I have signed two YouTube talents to the
network um it's Auntie Jenny and King
riches make sure you go subscribe to
both of their channels
um you know riches does more of like the
dating advice from like a guy's point of
view Auntie Jenny just dunks on
feminists it's a lot of fun
um
also guys
um again I know I've said this a million
times the show but I'm really trying to
get a big email list and a big phone
number list you guys don't have to do
both just do one or the other or both if
you want
um for the meetups and the events in
each City we really want to do a red
pill versus blue pill boxing Max Matt oh
my gosh I can't talk boxing match
um but we need to get enough emails to
put that together
who knows maybe
maybe maybe I'll fight another YouTuber
you know sign up for the email list sign
up okay I'm Sammy Robinson
um fave dressed you've worn Pearl try
overgrown curls guys I don't know how to
curl my hair like that's actually a
skill I've never learned whenever it's
done it's because my friend does it
um Jada Jade a special shout out to the
empty chair shut up at the end better
late than never
um tsunami thanks for delivering The
Knockout blow Pearl I won um Center mail
can you call the lack of communication
when there's no submission to hear your
input in order to have compromise lady
Emmanuel W Pearl Nicholas thank you for
the Super Chat okay
um other announcements make sure you
subscribe to wife school I'm kneading
bread soon so I don't whenever they
release that uh just probably thinks one
is my Instagram I'm also almost to 100K
on Twitter so go follow my Twitter
pearly things thank you I like them
thank you thank you
pearly things with the same
um we have just probably animations
we're also on Rumble
um
yeah I think that's it thanks for
watching guys subscribe to the channel
and we'll talk to you next time
bye
something
[Laughter]
what a way to end it here